si vous voulez nous allons nous allons
débuter notre matinée de
commission si vous voulez bien prendre
place madame puissa si vous voulez
bien alors mes chers collègues nous
entendons à présent Monsieur Thomas fatô
que j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
directeur général de l'acnam sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2024 j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible en vidéo à la
demande le pnfss déposé par le
Gouvernement décide une trajectoire
financière qui reste préoccupante pour
la branche maladie dont le déficit
semble se stabiliser autour de 10
milliards d'euros par an au moins
jusqu'en 2027 malgré un certain
dynamisme de ces
recettes l'évolution des comptes de la
branche reste l'un des enjeux majeurs
pour les comptes sociaux dans leur
ensemble regard du poids des dépenses de
maladie je remercie par avance les
intervenants par parce que je sais vous
serez nombreux à poser des questions
pour la concission de leurs propos je
soulligne à cet égard que nous disposons
d' 1h30 avant de passer à la suite de
notre ordre du jour pour pasêre plus
long Monsieur le Directeur Général vous
avez la parole pour un propos
liminminire dans lequel vous pourrez
nous présenter les principales mesures
du PLFSS et puis ensuite vous connaissez
l'exercice je donnerai en premier lieu
la parole au rapporteur puis à
l'ensembble de nos collègues Monsieur le
Directeur et bien c'est à vous merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
quelques mots peut-être en effet sur ce
projet de loi de financement d'abord
parce que vous l'avez évoqué souligner
le cadrage
financier qui peut-être vu je dirais de
de de deux manières d'abord un déficit
de l'assurance maladie qui serait sur
2023 divisé par 2 par rapport à 2022 ce
qui est quand même une bonne nouvelle
nous sortons en
2023 des déficits je sais pas quel est
le qualificatif àiso inédit
de l'assurance maladie en lien avec la
crise covid donc plus de 20 milliards en
2022 moins de 10 milliards en 2023 donc
tout de même une marche très importante
vers la réduction du déficit de
l'assurance maladie et je crois qu'il
faut s'en s'en
félicité certains commentateurs mais
avisés on ont noté que c'est ces
prévisions 2023 étai légèrement
supérieur à aux anticipations du
printemp c'est exact y compris parce que
l'inflation est restée élevée et que
reviendrait sans doute l'AM a porté des
dépenses plus importantes que
initialement prévu au au printemps mais
voilà je crois qu'il faut regarder tout
de même année après année et se
féliciter de voir l'assurance Malie
sortir de ces déficit très élevé covid
vous l'avez néanmoins rappelé la
trajectoire de l'assurance maladie reste
à des niveaux de déficit qui seraient
sur les 4 années de du du du de la
projection du projet de loi de
financement autour de de 9 milliards
d'euros donc ça reste évidemment un
sujet de de préoccupation et ça reste
pour l'Assurance Maladie une je dirais
motivation voir un un engagement certain
à démultiplier nos actions pour agir sur
la bonne utilisation des des ressources
de l'assurance maladie la la prévention
la gestion du risque la lutte contre les
abus et les fraudes on y reviendra très
certainement deuxème élément de ce
cadrage financier c'est c'est évidemment
l'ONDAM Onam à à à trois ,2 % euh qui
pourrait paraître facialement euh bar
puisque puisque moins élevé que que la
prévision don dam 2023 qui est à à 4,8 %
ce qui me permet de souligner à nouveau
les les lien entre l'inflation et et
londam certes londam et 2024 semblent
plus bas mais en réalité en lien avec
une prévision d'inflation qui euh euh
redescend très significativement 4 8 %
d'inflation en 2023 c'est la prévision
du gouvernement 2,5 % en 2024 et donc
quelque part un noname qui revient sur
des
zones plus élevées que l'inflation et si
on se dit que l'ONDAM c'est entre 2/3 et
3/4 de de rémunération à l'hôpital comme
en ville et puis de d'autres d'autres
éléments qui sont pas complètement sans
lien àvein l'inflation on peut noter que
nous revenons sur des niveaux qui voilà
permettent euh de financer euh les
transformations du système de santé euh
les investissements et d'accompagner euh
les différents projets prioritaires euh
du gouvernement et de l'assurance
maladie ce qui me permet au passage de
souligner que cet oname notamment permet
euh de porter
euh de financer euh un certain nombre de
de de revalorisations qui ont été
signées euh par l'assurance maladie au
prier semestre 2023 autant le début de
l'année 2023 a été difficile sur le plan
des relations conventionnelles avec
l'échec des négociations avec les
médecins et d'autres difficultés autant
le deuxè trimestre a été marqué par
beaucoup d'accords importants signés
avec les dentistes libéraux sur la
prévention et la démographie sur les
avec les masseurs kinésie thérapeutes
les infirmiers les biologistes les
transporteurs sanitaires les
orthophonistes les orthopstes les
sagesfemmes j'espère ne pas en oublier
euh et il s'agit pas de signer pour
signer mais de porter à la fois
d'ailleurs des réponse ponctuelle à
l'inflation puisque ces professions de
santé sont leur leur tarif est fixé
conventionnellement par l'assurance
maladie n'est pas indexé par par sur
l'inflation et donc il était important
de les ajuster mais aussi d'engager des
transformations plus de prévention avec
une rémunération de santé publique pour
les sages-femmes euh une vraie
régulation démographique de
l'installation des des masseur kinési
thérapeutes avec des réformes très
ambitieuse de cette profession mais mais
porté voilà par un accord pluriannuel et
donc c dam permet de financer ces
évolutions vous savez que les règles de
signature et de mise en œuvre des
accords fait que grosso modo les accords
qui sont signé au 2è premer semestre
2023 vont s'appliquer à comptter du
début de l'année 2024 puisqu'il y a la
fameuse règle des 6 mois de de de de
décalage entre les signatures et la mise
en œuvre des mesures de revalorisation
donc sont financé par londam 2024 et je
crois qu'il est important de le
souligner néanmoins et le gouvernement
l'a clairement indiqué égal quand il a
présenté je crois le la loi de
financement et et l'ONDAM euh cette le
respect d'un Nam à 3,2 implique des
mesures d'efficience à hauteur de
3,5 milliards d'euros dont le détail
figure dans le le dossier de presse de
la loi de financement et qui implique
notamment on y reviendra sans doute de
l'assurance maladie je le disais des
efforts renforcés en matière de de
maîtrise médicalisée de bon usage du du
médicament nous avons commencé à
pardonnez-moi à euh travailler
évidemment à renforcer nos actions
autour notamment du bon usage du
médicament de la meilleure maîtrise des
des volumes de médicaments qui fait écho
également à au rapport qui a été remis à
la première ministre sur globalement la
régulation du des industries de de santé
vous m'invitez à présenter ou en tout
cas euh euh intervenir sur le un certain
nombre de mesures de la loi de
financement peut-être partager avec la
commission euh
euh comment dirais-je la la satisfaction
je sais pas si c'est le bon terme en
tous les cas le fait que ce projet de
loi reprend un certain nombre de
propositions que l'assurance maladie a
fait dans son rapport annuel charg et
produits que je suis sûr vous n'avez pas
manqué de de de lire pendant peut-être
la pause estivale je pense notamment à
la valorisation des transports partagés
euh puisque ça faisait partie des
mesures que nous proposions comment nous
favorisons des des des dépenses plus
efficientes de transport également
d'ailleurs contribution à la
décarbonation du système de santé des
propositions autour des transferts et
des évolutions de de tâches entre les
professionnels de santé sujet sensible
nous avions proposé que les pharmaciens
puissent délivrer des des antibiotiques
après des la réalisation de trod pour
les engines ou des ou de tests pour les
infections urinaires le gouvernement
reprend
cette proposition nous avions également
proposé de revenir sur un sujet bien
connu y compris du Sénat sur la
l'encadrement de la prescription d'arrêt
de travail par les téléconsultation donc
là aussi le gouvernement reprend euh
cette proposition de de de limiter la
prescription d'arrêt de travail à à des
arrêts courts de de 3 jours permettant
le cas échéant à l'assurée de d'avoir du
temps pour consulter un un un médecin
pour le cas échéant prolonger cette
arrêt de travail et puis également même
si c'est pas exactement la même mesure
euh se se se féliciter si je peux me
permettre euh de mesur autour de la
réduction de l'impact environnemental de
l'utilisation des dispositifs médicaux
nous avions fait également des
propositions le mode d'emploi n'est pas
strictement identique mais ça va
évidemment dans le bon sens d'une
décarbonation du système de santé qui
représente vous le savez 8 % des
émissions carbone de notre pays ce qui
est tout de même considérable la moitié
ce sont des des produits de santé dont
des des dispositifs euh médicaux au-delà
évidemment euh le PLFSS ne se limite pas
à reprendre les propositions de
l'Assurance Maladie fustent-ell
excellente euh partager avec vous euh la
mobilisation de l'assurance maladie sur
notamment des mesures importantes en
matière de prévention qui sont portées
par cette loi de de financement autour
de de la vaccination avec la campagne
HPV autour de mesures de protection la
prise en charge à 100 % des des des
préservatifs pour les jeunes des
protections menstruelles
réutilisablebles pour les les moins de
26 ans et les bénéficiaires de la c2z
autour bien sûr d'ajustement des bilans
de prévention qui vont commencer à se
déployer cet automne et puis nous
contribuerons bien sûr également à la
mise en place de ce service de de
repérage et d'accompagnement précoce qui
fait la qui prolonge ce qui est déjà
engagé au travers des des plateformes de
d'orientation du plan autisme et à
laquelle nous sommes parties prenantes
et je crois qui permet d'améliorer la
prise en charge des des enfants et bien
sûr des des familles euh cette loi de
financement elle elle elle prévoit
également des mesures importantes en
terme d'évolution de l'organisation du
système de soins j'ai évoqué les mesures
sur les délégation de tâche je vais pas
toutes les reprendre passage dans le
droit commun des des articles des
expérimentations dites article 51
transformation du financement de la T2A
même si nous ne sommes pas évidemment
leader entre guillemets en en la matière
permanence des soins dentaires autant de
autant de mesures qui vont permettre re
de confirmer des évolutions
d'organisation du du système de soins
qui sont évidemment indispensables vu
les tensions qui s'exercent sur le
système de santé deux derniers points et
pardon monsieur le Président si ce
propos liminire est un peu peut-être est
un peu long
euh vous l'avez peut-être vu nous avons
fait la semaine dernière un bilan
d'étape sur nos travaux de lutte contre
la fraude et et montrer la la dynamique
à l'œuvre nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
devant cette commission de partager à
plusieurs reprises ces travaux la loi de
financement va continuer à nous donner
des des outils complémentaires de lutte
contre les abus et les fraudes je pense
par exemple à la à la suspension
l'annulation de la participation de
l'assurance maladie aux cotisations des
à la prise en charge des cotisations des
professionnels dans le cas dans le cas
de de fraude je pense aux mesures sur le
renforcement du contrôle des des arrêts
de de travail notamment et puis dernier
volet qui est un volet
substantiel de ce de ce projet de
financement beaucoup de mesures sur
l'accès au médicaments l'accès aux
médicaments innovants la lutte contre
les les pénuries qui relève pour un
certain nombre de ces mesures
directement du ministère de la Santé de
la prévention ou du comité économique
des produits de santé ou de ou de
mécanisme de de fixation des prix mais
qui mais auquel nous allons évidemment
participer puisque nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs à la fois à
l'accès à l'innovation à l'accès au aux
médicaments matures et de ce point de
vue-là je crois que le le projet de loi
porte un certain nombre de mesures
tentees qui vont dans le sens de
garantir à nos assurés euh un accès euh
encore une fois aux différentes
molécules nous avions là encore pardon
de reciter à nouveau charg et produits
illustrait dans notre rapport euh la
performance du système français souvent
décrié mais qui de fait quand on le
compare de façon euh équitable et
transparente avec les autres pays et
perform en matière d'innovation d'accès
à aux molécules innovantes et que les
dépenses aujourd'hui sont très fortement
impactées par
la dynamique de l'innovation et des prix
qui vont avec si vous me permettez cette
expression un tout petit peu rapide et
triviale voilà Monsieur le le le
président ce que je peux dire en propos
liminire sur ce projet de loi de
financement pour 2024 merci Monsieur le
Directeur et bien je vais tout de suite
donner la la parole à ellisabeth donanau
notre rapporteur général puis ensuite ce
sera au tour de corineber merci monsieur
le Président j'espère que l'ensemble de
mes collègues m'entendent bien parce que
je suis obligé de de conserver le le
masque encore quelques temps
euh Monsieur le Directeur merci pour ces
éléments liminire je voudrais aussi dire
à à mes nouvelles collègues parce que je
crois que c'est plutôt féminin ce matin
les nouvelles collègues que c'est c'est
la première réunion de travail sur le
PLFSS donc en recevant la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie on va les
un et les autres essayer d'investiguer
en tout cas de de porter des des des
questions euh des questions qu'on a
entendu pendant dans dans nos campagnes
électorales hein et donc c'est vraiment
un temps pour comprendre et puis pour
avoir des réponses donc il y a aucune
question qui sont tabou moi je vais
poser plutôt les questions financières
budgétaires mais à vous de vous lancer
sur toutes les questions qui relèvent de
la santé Monsieur le Directeur général
il est là pour ça pour y répondre donc
euh je vais être un petit peu longue
monsieur le Président parce que j'ai
quand même quelques questions euh
concernant les l'aspect financier alors
mes premières questions c'est sur la
revue des dépenses
d'abord lundi prochain nous aurons en
débat dans l'hémicycle la loi sur la
programmation comment dirais-je des
finances publiques elle sera examinée
donc en nouvelle lecture nous ne sommes
pas saisis au niveau de la commission he
ça je tiens à le préciser pour mes
collègues aussi qui qui démarrent
l'article 17 prévoit des économies à
hauteur de 6 milliards d'euros euh pour
les années 2025 à 2027 euh c'est surtout
c'est ce qui nous intéresse elles sont
réparties en fait
ces comment c'estes ces recettes en tout
cas ces dépenses ou oui c'est ces
économies de dépenses sur les
administrations de sécurité sociale les
administrations de sécurité sociale vous
verrez que le le terme c'est assaut dans
tous nos documents hein vous vous allez
apprendre aussi des acronymes la CNAM
est-elle associé d'abord à ses revues de
dépenses et en clair est-ce qu'il y a un
objectif d'économie qui lui a été fixé
ça c'est la première question toujours
sur les revues de dépenses les coûts de
gestion des caisses de sécurité sociale
sont mentionnées dans le rapport annuel
au Parlement publié en juillet dernier
qu'en est-il pour laacnam et quel est
les économies encore
envisageables 3è point sur cette revue
de dépenses la cour des compte a publié
aussi en juillet dernier une note
thématique relative à la médecine de
ville où elle Pr préconise une réforme
des modalités de négociation de
l'assurance maladie avec les
professionnels de santé vous en avez un
peu parlé de ces négociations et les
producteur de produits de santé aussi
quel est votre avis sur les pistes
d'économie et la dernière question sur
ce sujet Quel serait selon vous les
autres revues de dépenses possibles pour
laacnam sans évidemment altérer la
qualité
des réponse à la population en terme de
santé maintenant j'attaque le le PLFSS à
Pr donc l'article 7 l'article 7 en fait
il s'agit d'annuler la participation de
l'assurance maladie à la prise en charge
des cotisations des praticiens et
auxiliaires médicaux en cas de fraude
nous étions réunis hier matin monsieur
le directeur pour cette nouvelle entité
hein qui a vu le jour avec la lutte
contre les fraudes et je trouvais très
intéressant que chaque caisse puisse
apporter les détails de comment
dirais-je de de cette force de frappe si
on peut dire en tout cas d'investigation
encore pour chercher la fraude donc dans
le cas d'un contrôle qui est diligenté
là part les URSAF est-ce que vous avez
en fait ce lien avec les URSAF et dans
ce
cas je pense que vous pouvez donc être
sous le coup de l'article 7 qui est
proposé mais sinon le professionnel de
santé échapperait-il à l'annulation de
la prise en charge des
cotisations l'article 11 du PLFSS c'est
sur la simplification des mécanismes de
régulation macroéconomique des produits
de santé on en a aussi beaucoup parlé au
mois de juillet avec la plaxe puisque
nous avions noté les uns et les autres
que cette clause de sauvegarde qui
intervient lorsque le volume des
produits de santé a dépassé une certaine
limite auprès des des producteurs et en
fait c'est une taxe enfin un impôt si on
qui qui les pénalise et donc ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que depuis quelques
années ce montant va euh de façon
exponentiel augmenté et donc pour 2023
par exemple on était à 100 Millard et
pour 2024 on prévoit 2 milliards d'euros
or euh donc sur l'article 11 l'objectif
l'objectif préconisé par la Mission
borne puisque ça a été diligenté cette
dernière ces derniers mois sur la
régulation des dépenses de produits de
santé est de ramener à moyen terme ce
montant la clause de sauvegarde à 0,5
milliards d'euros
est-ce que selon vous c'est possible
d'accélérer ou pas ou d'avoir un autre
une autre
temporalité est-ce que vous pensez aussi
que on pourrait maîtriser davantage les
volumes tout en augmentant les les
baisses de prix et je dirais tout en
ayant une vigilance sur la pénurie des
médicaments parce que c'est là la la le
sujet je sais que la mission borne a
donc lancé en quelque sorte un New Deal
qu'en est-il est-ce qu'il est possible
de d'avoir cette régulation tout en
ayant une la fourniture des des des
médicaments en temps utile
euh je je vais peut-être m'arrêter là
sur ce volume à l'aveugle et puis
l'article 31 simplement c'est sur
l'établissement français du sang vous
allez voir chaque année il y a un
certain nombre d'interventions dans
l'hémicycle sur le FS et c'est tout à
fait normal puisqu'on est tous concernés
dans notre territoire et souvent on nous
dit mais le problème Mme de l'fs c'est
aujourd'hui de pouvoir
budgétairement continuer à rendre le
service avec Annie lewiirou on a rendu
un rapport sur les organismes qui sont
financés de plus en plus par la Sécurité
sociale on a reçu le FS ils nous ont dit
leur inquiétude et elle est tout à fait
justifiée puisque d'ailleurs l'état l'
la l'a pris en compte he puisque il y a
des dotations supplémentaires qui sont
attribué euh quel est votre avis
sur cette nouvelle dotation qui serait
en fait en fait inscrite dans le marbre
est-ce que vous trouvez normal puisque
là en fait cette dotation elle
financerait des des obligations de
service public est-ce que vous trouverz
normal que ce soit bien à l'assurance
maladie et non pas à l'état de de de de
régler ce ce sujet merci de votre
attention merci Madame la rapporteur
beaucoup de beaucoup de questions je
donne maintenant la la parole à Corine
hber et comme ça on répondra directement
à nos deux intervenantes merci monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur le Directeur
Général mes chers collègues en tant que
rapporteur de de la branche maladie
Monsieur le Directeur général je
m'interroge sur la soutenabilité
financière de cette branche alors que l'
dame dépassera en
2024 plus de de 250 milliards je
m'interrogeais déjà l'année dernière sur
la spectaculaire amélioration annoncée
du sol de l'assurance Malie dans un
contexte économique particulièrement
incertain force et et malheureusement de
constater que la prudence du Sénat était
était bien justifiée en effet ce qui
semblait être une heureuse embellie et
je le rappelle pour nos collègues un
PLFSS 2022 on anon sait à l'horizon 2025
un déficit de 4,4 milliards d'euros en
2023 on l'annonçait à
4,8 nous sommes loin des des 10
milliards j'allais dire qui sont
inscrits dans ce PLFSS 2024 10 milliards
j'allais dire qui qui se dont le niveau
reste jusqu'en 2027 annoncé comme
déficit de la branche maladie quand un
déficit s'installe de manière aussi
durable quel pilotage des dépenses
peut-on décemment prétendre l'assurance
maladie comme toutes les branches doit
ménager un équilibre entre ces recettes
et ses dépenses comment selon vous le
retrouver et éviter pour l'Assurance
Maladie rien de moins que la banque
route
honnêtement aujourd'hui pour avoir
commencé les
auditions même si on pourrait saluer
l'augmentation de l'endam
euh comment en même temps justifier
l'économie et l'effort assumé de 3,5
milliards d'euros donc qu'est-ce qu'on
va pas financer avec ce tondam de 250
milliards aujourd'hui c'est ça la
question qui est posée notamment du côté
des établissements de de santé donc
clairement il va y avoir des choix
douloureux est-ce que vous pourriez nous
en dire un peu
plus l'article 22 du PLFSS vis a
facilité la généralisation
d'expérimentation en santé et on
pourrait s'en réjouir il faut intervenir
des professionnels de santé euh dont le
le
la rémunération va être fixée par
arrêté d'habitude mes collègues le
savent toutes les rémunérations
honoraire vers au professionnel de santé
discuter de façon conventionnelle lors
des négociations conventionnelles et on
voit et c'est le cas pour les
rendez-vous de prévention où les
professionnels de santé seraient
également rémunérés avec des tarifs
fixés par arrêté alors au-delà du fait
qu'on voit des disparité entre les
professionnels de santé pour un même
acte et même si elle est plus lourde et
et vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir
la négociation conventionnelle avec les
professionnels de santé ne doit pas ne
doit pas être préférée chaque fois que
c'est possible sur l'article 27 du plf6
qui vise à régurerer les dépenses
d'indemnité journalière pour arrêt de
travail pouvez-vous nous dire dans
quelle mesure votre feuille de route est
limitée par le droit en vigueur et en
quoi il est nécessaire que l'article 27
modifie le cadre
législatif enfin sur l'article 35 du
PLFSS qui vise à mettre en place une
prise en charge dérogatoire et
temporaire en sus est arrivrive
hospitalier pour certains médicaments en
fin de prise en charge au titre de
l'accès
précoce les médicaments concernés sont
ceux non inscrits sur la liste en sus au
terme de la période d'accès précos faute
d'amélioration suffisante du service
médical rendu en l'attente de données
supplémentaires estimez-vous que le
bénéfice tiré de la sécurisation de la
prise en charge des médicaments
concernés dont le niveau d'efficacité ne
demeurant pas garanti justifie le surcût
occasionné pour l'assurance maladie
estimé à 39 millions d'euros par l'étude
d'impact et à quel niveau la décôte
réduisant le la prise en charge des
médicaments concerné devrait-elle selon
vous s'établir voilà un peu technique
cette question mais
important cont tenu des choix politiques
fait depuis plusieurs années de
faciliter l'accès à l'innovation pour
nos concitoyens pour les malades ce qui
est une bonne chose mais à quel prix et
on voit qu' en plus les résultats sont
pas attendus quel sera le niveau décote
euh évoqué dans cet article je vous
remercie merci Corine Monsieur le
Directeur je vous laisse répondre à aux
questions de nos deux intervenantes
merci merci beaucoup
euh peut-être tout d'abord madame la
rapporteur sur les sujets que vous
évoqué sur les les économies et les revu
de dépenses
euh le ministère des comptes publiques
il y a quelques mois je crois fait le le
point d'étape sur les les revues de
dépenses un certain nombre d'entre elles
traité en effet des sujets d'assurance
maladie je pense aux arrêts de travail
et pour ce qui est de la
contribution de l'assurance maladie aux
économies dites assaut comme comme vous
le le rappelez elles sont de 3,5
milliards d'euros c'est très clairement
présenté par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de du dossier de de presse de du
loi de de la loi de financement avec un
certain nombre d'éléments de détail sur
ces 3,5 milliards donc clairement nous
contribuons au quantum d'économie qui
participe euh de la politique de
finances publi du du gouvernement on
pourra y revenir si vous le si vous le
le souhaitez puisque ce ce 3,5 milliards
est détaillé dans le cadrage financier
de la loi de de de financement
euh sagissant des des coûts de gestion
euh je je partage avec vous peut-être
deux chiffres éclairants qui sont
présentés dans le cadre de rapport que
nos collègues de la direction la
recherche et des études du ministère de
la Santé l'adresse publie chaque année
sur les comptes de la santé les coûts de
gestion de de l'assurance maladie
obligatoire était en 2012 de 6,9
milliards d'euros 6,9 milliards d'euros
ils sont en 2022 dernier chiffre
officiellement connu de
6,7 milliards d'euros nous avons
continué depuis 10 ans à faire des
économies de gestion importantes euh du
côté de l'assurance maladie je ne
regarderai pas les autres postes des
autres organismes qui gèent des dépenses
de santé la trajectoire n'est pas
exactement la même mais en tous les
cas c'est c'est une voilà une maîtrise
substantielle nous avons rendu plus de
20 % des effectifs de l'assurance
maladie depuis plus de 15 ans et nous
sommes la branche qui qui allons qui va
continuer à rendre des des emplois sur
la période
2023-2027 puisque nous allons rendre
1700 emploi euh sur cette période nous
continuons à faire des des gains
d'efficience à redéployer des moyens euh
sur la prévention sur la gestion du
risque sur la lutte contre la frose sur
le service aux assurés et donc euh je
crois que de ce point de vue-là euh
l'assurance maladie obligatoire est
exemplaire en matière de réduction euh
et de maîtrise de ces coûts de gestion
tout en euh euh maintenance sa qualité
de service son maillage territorial même
si euh la crise évidemment a été euh euh
un euh challenge si j'ose dire pardon de
cet anglicisme pour les équipes de
l'Assurance
Maladie vous m'interrogez sur les
négociations avec les professionnels de
santé les rapports de la Cour des
comptes je je je rejoins bien volontiers
la cour sur sur l'importance de
l'interprofessionnalité c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous travaillons en ce
moment même avec l'UNPS l'Union
nationale et professionnels de santé à à
définir dans le cadre de des évolutions
de ce qu'on appelle la CP l'accord cadre
interprofessionnel euh un programme de
travail euh avec euh voilà le ces
professions pour essayer quelque part de
de partir c'est ce que la Cour des
comptes nous invite à faire de partir
des enjeux de la coordination des soins
de l'interprofessionnalité puis de
décliner euh via les discussions
monoprofessionnelles pardon de
d'utiliser ce type de langage et plutôt
que dans l'autre sens euh c'est bien ce
que nous souhaitons vous m'interroger
sur le lien avec les économies euh euh
en tout cas très clairement euh pour moi
le dialogue conventionnel et les accords
conventionnels sont aussi un levier
pour porter des mécanism participant à
la qualité à la pertinence des soins et
je pense qu'avec les négociations qui
j'espère vont se rouvrir avec les
médecins libéraux puis avec les
pharmaciens nous aurons des enjeux sur
ces thématique évidemment très
importante sagissant de de la mesure de
du PLFSS et de l'article 7 c'est
euh la collaboration avec les services
de l'URSAF et est est totale hein sur
cette mesure elle qui vise à à à à à
faire que lorsque nous identifions des
des fraudes et et et j'insiste sur le
fait que c'est au terme d'une
condamnation soit de pénalité financière
soit une condamnation pénale euh nous
allons récupérer les la prise en charge
des cotisations sociales en plus entre
guillemets l'indu c'est vrai qu'il est
assez paradoxal que finalement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui euh nous sommes face à une
dépense frauduleuse nous récupérons
l'argent éventuellement il a une
pénalité mais euh les cotisations
sociales que nous avons pris en charge
et qui sont lié à ces dépenses
redigieuses nous ne les récupérions pas
et donc je pense que de ce point de
vue-là l'article de ce PLFSS est
pertinent et il se mettra en œuvre en
bonne intelligence avec les services de
de l'URSAF pas de difficulté là-dessus
vous m'interrogez sur la clause de de
sauvegarde et le et le New Deal
euh alors c'est évidemment des des
équations complexes euh euh je crois que
le le le le le gouverne ouvernement
cherche un un nouvel équilibre ou un New
Deal en bon français
pour dans la régulation de des dépenses
de des produits de santé entre les la
régulation par les prix et la régulation
par les volumes et au sein de cette
régulation par les prix
entre pardon de rentrer un peu dans la
technique mais la baisse de des baisses
de prix sur les sur les les prix faciaux
les remises qui donc aboutissent à un
prix net des médicaments et puis des
mécanismes plus collectifs et notamment
de la clause de sauvegarde il a il a
fixé un objectif de euh maîtrise on va
dire de du rendement de la clause de
sauvegarde euh qui c'est vrai est monté
à des niveaux très importants euh euh
voilà c'est un équilibre je crois qu'il
est pertinent de de trouver pour ce qui
nous concerne euh principalement euh
notre engagement il est en effet avant
tout sur une meilleure maîtrise des
volumes de de médicaments euh puisque il
est vrai que les euh euh levier ou les
gisements en tout cas d'inefficience
existe euh on là aussi euh nous essayons
de les identifier chaque année et et et
chaque cette année encore dans notre
rapport annuel nous avons diagnostiqué
un certain nombre de situations et
proposé un certain nombre de de mesures
euh nous nous continuons à même si nous
avons beaucoup réduit euh ces dernières
années nous continuons à à consommer 20
% de plus d'antibiotiques que la moyenne
des pays européens euh euh nous notons
euh une polym indication des personnes
âgées qui restent à des niveaux élevés
quand bien même elle a aussi tout de
même diminué donc les efforts menés
permettent de réduire le niveaux globaux
mais il reste à des niveaux importants
et plus importants que la moyenne de nos
voisins européens donc les les leviers
ex enfin en tout cas les les sources
d'inéfficience existe je permets au
passage même si c'est peut-être
difficile à à percevoir mais si nous
arrivions à mieux
maîtriser et à revenir vers la moyenne
des pays européens sur certaines classes
thérapeutiques ça participerait
également d'une lutte efficace contre la
la pénurie je pense par exemple aux
antibiotiques euh et et et d'où
d'ailleurs des mesures pour pour
valoriser l'utilisation du trod 1
million de 9 million d'engines par an 1
million seulement de trod utilisé ça
montre qu'il y a des voies de progrès je
néanmoins je je partage aussi avec la
avec vous
euh voilà le le le le le fait de de
faire changer ces c'estes c'estes c'est
d'aboutir à des résultats dans ces
domaines c'est changer des comportements
individuel de prescription c'est changer
des organisations c'est créer les
incitations à agir euh en ville comme à
l'hôpital et donc c'est c'est des choses
que nous allons euh renforcer pour 2024
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle feuille de
route sur le bon usage du médicament
mais il est certain que voilà le les les
défis sont importants vous m'interrogez
également sur
euh le FS
euh pour vous répondre oui je je je
pense que euh
le le le l'évolution du mode de
financement de l'Établissement français
du sang qui distingue d'un côté des
tarifs réglementés liés à son activité
grosso modo et de l'autre des missions
de service public financé par des
dosations me semble être logique et
pertinente est-ce que c'est à l'État ou
à l'assurance maladite financé si
j'étais si j'étais impertinent je dirais
que ça fait longtemps que que que
l'assurance maladie finance l'ensemble
desmions de service public du système de
santé quelle qu'en soit la nature ou à
peu près la totalité ce qui me paraît
logique on n'imagine pas les hôpitaux
financés par l'État et et pourtant ils
remplissent des missions de service
public en tous les cas c'est le c'est
voilà c'est c'est c'est la le rôle et
le le cœur de la mission de de
l'Assurance Maladie donc ça me paraît ça
me paraît cohérent l'histoire montre que
les doubles financements en plus sont
généralement des choses extrêmement
compliquées à gérer qui se terminent de
toute façon à la fin par un financement
intégral par l'Assurance Maladie donc il
y a pas beaucoup de de suspense
euh madame la rapporteur sur les
sujets sur les sujets
financiers je je je me permets de de
rebondir sur votre question et sur la la
façon que vous avez eu de la formuler
euh on entend on entend légitimement des
représentants
euh en ville comme à l'hôpital pointer
les limites de l'ONDAM 2024 les
insuffisances de financement on entend
aussi des acteurs dire mais il y a
beaucoup d'économie à faire est-ce qu'il
y a pas trop d'économie à faire et puis
c'est V vous l'avez dit une perspective
financière de l'assurance maladie encore
une fois je je je me permets de partager
avec vous mais vous vous connaissez
parfaitement bien ce su donc vous le
savez les les incertitudes qui sont
liées à une prévision pluriannuelle des
objectifs financiers de l'assurance
maladie à forceori dans les contextes
que nous avons connu de crise et et
d'inflation qui sont des exercices
extrêmement délicats et si on se
regardait les perspectives qui étaient
en 2021 ou en 2022 on verrait des
déficits qui étaient prévus pour être
nettement plus élevés sur 24 et 25 donc
je voilà donc donc tout ça pour dire que
est-ce qu'il y a trop d'économie est-ce
qu'il y a pas assez de financement euh
on entend beaucoup de choses qui sont
honnêtement légitime euh ça montre en
effet l'extrême
difficulté
de la chose et pour ce qui qui qui
relève pardon de renvoyer la balle au
aux représentants au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien sûr au
gouvernement de débat politique sur les
finances publiques les finances sociales
euh l'équilibre des différentes branches
pour ce qui est de l'assurance maladie
je le disais en introduction en tous les
cas ça ne fait que renforcer
l'importance de notre mission en terme
de gestion du risque d'efficience des
des dépenses puisque nous avons à
contribuer au 3,5 milliards d'économies
qui sont identifié dans londam 2024 et
dont une bonne part relève sur des
programmes de de maîtrise médicalisé de
lutte contre la fraude et donc c'est ça
notre
mission principale
sur l'article 22 et le la bascule en
droit commun de l'article 51 en tout cas
des
expérimentation
euh pour rien vous cacher nous avons eu
des discussions avec le ministère de la
Santé les équipes du du ministre et des
directions sur ces sujets-là est-ce
qu'il fallait tout revenir tout repasser
vers le conventionnel ou ou passer par
l'arrêté on est en réalité euh
euh face à des expérimentations qui sont
souvent multi euh inter ou
multiprofessionnelles euh euh qui du
coup euh euh s'accommoderait mal de de
négociations qui devrait être soit
monoprofessionnelle mais multiples soit
interprofessionnelle et elle est quand
même délicate euh moi je n'ai pas de
doute que euh lorsque les arrêtés seront
préparés euh l'assurance maladie en lien
avec les professionnels de santé sera
euh consulté voir davantage euh pour que
ces tarifications prises par Arrêté soit
cohérente au regard des niveaux fixés de
manière conventionnelle nous l'avons euh
pratiqué à de multiples reprises et
Monsieur de La ganerie qui est avec moi
qui s'occupe des produits de santé à
l'Assurance Maladie s'en souvient sur
toute la la vaccination les tests covid
sur lequel on a on a vécu pendant 2ux ou
3 ans avec que des arrêtés la pratique
était que l'assurance maladie ne
négocier pas parce que c'était pas
arrêté mais discuter des niveaux de
tarif et qu'à la fin il y avait en bonne
intelligence avec les équipes bien sûr
des ministres mais qu'à la fin ça se
terminait par un arrêté et donc je crois
que de ce point de vue-là c'est assez
pragmatique comme comme solution mais ça
doit rester l'exception puisque que je
crois comme vous mais là je prêche pour
ma paroisse que le dialogue
conventionnel doit être d'abord la
première façon de fixer les tarifs avec
les professions de santé vous
m'interrogez sur l'article 27 le
contrôle des arrêts de travail ça me
permet de confirmer l'engagement de
l'assurance maladie sur un plan complet
euh transversal sur le le contrôle des
arrêts travail pourquoi je dis contrôle
complet transversal c'est que il
s'applique à la fois aux assurés aux
prescripteurs et aux entreprises et
qu'il qu'il s'appuie à la fois sur des
levier de contrôle mais aussi
d'accompagnement d'information de
prévention et donc il est il se veut en
tout cas transversal
euh le sujet que qui est traité dans cet
article 27 il est je crois il est plus
ponctuel il a trait euh au contrôle
réalisé à la demande d'employeur par des
médecins contrôleurs euh et de la la
traduction de ces contrôles pour les
services de l'Assurance Maladie euh ça
n'est en aucune mesure une délégation du
contrôle de l'Assurance Maladie une
externalisation n nous nous nous menons
nos opérations de contrôle on n' pas
besoin de de de délégataire ou
d'externaliser nos nos contrôles euh
voilà je je crois simplement que le le
le l'article fait un certain nombre de
d'ajustement dans les partage
d'information les traductions de
contrôle opérés par par ces médecins je
précise au passage que euh la la la
suspension des d'arrêt travail qui qui
est prévu dans le casre de d'un contrôle
réalisé par un un un un médecin
contrôleur digidenté par l'employeur
n'interviendrait que si le médecin
contrôleur a effectivement examiné le
patient et a effectivement pu mesurer si
l'arrêt travail était ou non justifié si
comme ça arrive un certain nombre de
fois puisque ces contrôles sont fait à
domicile si euh en fait il y a absence
et donc pas pas de possibilité de de
contrôle effectif de l'assurée alors il
y a pas suspension automatique donc on
est sur alors le contrôle le service
médical devra convoquer l'assurée et et
examiner laassur donc il il y a pas
d'automaticité de la suspension d'arrêt
travail sans que le service médical est
vu le patient je pense que c'est un un
élément extrêmement
important sur l'accès précoce en en
renouvelant évidemment notre attachement
à ces mécanismes qui participe d'une
d'un accès aux assurés de médicaments
innovants en amont même des phases de
discussion si vous me le permettez
Monsieur président passer la parole à
Monsieur de lag ganerie qui pourra
apporter un élément d'expertise vous
l'avez dit Madame la rapporteur sur un
article technique je laisse monsieur de
la ganerie préciser les choses sur
notamment les fixations des des des prix
et des tarifs oui merci beaucoup euh en
effet sujet très technique mais une
grande importance euh on sait que
l'accès précoce est un dispositif euh
qui fonctionne depuis 2 ans il a été
réformé c'est plus de 2 milliards
d'euros de dépenses qui ont été euh euh
versé euh au titre du financement de ces
médicaments en accès précoce donc on
comprend l'importance de ce dispositif
euh cette article vient amender
améliorer certains aspects de de ce
dispositif en améliorant l'accès au
vaccin en d'imposant aux industriels un
engagement en terme de de fourniture des
médicaments qui sont en accès précoce en
lien avec notamment les sujets pénuries
c'est-à-dire on vous finance un accès
précoce mais vous vous engagez à nous
fournir le produit et dans les quantités
suffisantes donc il y a il y a des
avancées sur le sujet donc de euh la
prise en charge suite à l'évaluation
donc avec une amélioration du service
médical rendu finalement du médicament
en asmr
5 donc pas d'amélioration du service
Méal rendu par rapport aux alternatives
existantes l'idée c'est de garantir la
continuité de
traitement on comprend bien que lorsque
des patients ont accès à ces médicaments
l'arrêt peut être problématique et donc
l'idée c'est de le financer et de de
garantir une une continuité de
traitement pour ces patients alors
évidemment nous je je vais rappeler
aussi la la lecture du rapport chargé
produit on a des des propositions sur
les asmr5 sur les asmrc sur les décodes
qui sont vraiment importante pour
essayer de trouver un équilibre avec le
financement de l'innovation puisqu'on
voit que ces dernières années sur les
trois dernières années on a eu très
forte hausse des dépenses à l'innovation
et donc il faut arriver à avoir des
mécanismes de décote
assez mécaniquees sur les asmr 5 et et
4 dans ce qui est proposé dans la mesure
c'est notamment de prendre le plus bas
prix du corridor européen pour la
fixation du prix d'appliquer une décôte
qui est ici une décôte dans l'étude
d'impacte de 20 % et des remises de 50 %
donc il y a un cadre
après je pense deux choses euh il y aura
du cas par cas sans doute en fonction
des des produits et par ailleurs l'étude
d'impact et l'impact économique est basé
sur le passé évidemment c'est toujours
compliqué de prévoir très bien les
innovations et donc peut-être que ce
disposittif n'aura pas d'impact
financier mais en tout cas voilà c'est
sur le passé il y a SEP médicaments qui
auraient pu bénéficier de ce dispositif
là et c'est comme ça que l'impact
économique a été calculé euh donc après
sur les des côes de 20 % on est sur des
côes assez classiques des asmr 5 euh
dans la politique de liée à l'accord
cadre mise en place par le comité
économique des produits de santé donc
c'est ça qui rejoint cette
proposition bien merci euh monsieur pour
ces réponse alors on va donner la parole
on aujourd'hui pour l'instant 11
demandes de de prise de parole euh avant
de commencer moi je je vais vous poser
une première question Monsieur le
Directeur on est beaucoup sollicité par
un com de concitoyens sur les enjeux
concernant le covid long et ma question
c'est voilà dans la prise quelle est la
prise en compte qui a été faite par par
par l'assurance maladie sur notamment la
classification et et les moyens
financiers voilà et donc je donne tout
de suite maintenant la parole à Bernard
jumier merci euh monsieur mon Président
donc je vais m'entenir à trois questions
voilà mais une remarque préliminaire
puisque monsieur d'abord merci monsieur
le directeur pour vos vos votre exposé
très dense vous êtes fait le le le
défenseur du cadrage du gouvernement
mais moi je constate donc vous me
permettrez de faire une remarque
préliminaire qui est de constater que
les comptes sociaux se dégradent de
nouveau que la sécurité sociale est donc
mal gérée et de rappeler qu'en 2017-28
ils étaient quasiment à l'équilibre et
que les perspectives de réduction qui
avaient été fixé sont déjà démenties par
les chiffres actuels et le retour à
l'équilibre ne sera ni pour 2025 ni pour
2026 ni pour 2027 si on poursuit dans
dans ce sillon là cette remarque
préliminaire faite ma première question
porte au fond sur les résultats vous
êtes vous gérez le le budget santé du
pays en gros ENF sous la tutelle du
ministère bien sûr mais vous avez en
charge le budget santé du pays et on
juge évidemment au résultat qui sont les
indicateurs de santé du pays qui
évoluent lentement mais qui évoluent et
les deux principaux indicateur de santé
que sont la mortalité infantile il se
dégrade de façon régulière donc quelles
sont les mesures qu'est-ce qui comment
est analysé cette dégradation et quelle
allocation de moyen et à quelle
allocation de moyen est-il procédé pour
remettre remédier à cette dégradation
mais maintenant c'est le premier
indicateur qui se dégrade et de façon
signific c'est l'espérance de vie
puisque notre pays et c'est inédit
recule dans l'OCDE de la 6e à la 13e
place à la 13e place c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est dans le le PAP 2024 donc
c'est un document interne au ministère
document du ministère de la Santé je
crois que ça veut dire projet de
performance ou je ne sais plus
exactement ce que dit cet acronyme et
qui parle d'un léger recul en parlant de
ce recul de la 6e à 13e place nous
sommes en train de dégrader notre
système de santé au point qu'il devient
alors plus du tout le meilleur système
du monde ça ça fait longtemps mais un
système très moyen donc je veux dire on
a quand même une interrogation parce que
est- à dire que la loocation de moyens
n'est pas faite sur les bonnes
politiques et sur les bons acteurs ma
deuxème question euh porte sur la
question de la pertinence ça fait
longtemps que ce sujet sur la table de
la pertinence des soins on se souvient
que agès Buzin en faisait un un marqueur
fort de de sa politique elle citait des
des chiffres de 20 30 % dans le secteur
de ville d'actes qui étit inuti et
redondant donc tout un travail comment
comptez-vous avancer sur la pertinence à
l'URE de la financiarisation de notre
système et je vais prendre juste
l'exemple de l'imagerie l'imagerie est
un secteur en pleine financiarisation
c'est déjà un secteur où la pertinence
des soins on va dire n'était pas la plus
optimale pour rester dans le fémisme
mais là maintenant euh cette
financierisation induit une dérive
totale dans la recherche de profit et
donc comment allez-vous faire pour
avancer sur la pertinence euh au-delà
des discussions conventionnelles quand
il y a cet éléphant qui est au milieu de
la pièce et ma troisème et dernière
question euh portera sur les politiques
de prévention je je salue tout à fait
les préventions
médicalisées que vous avez rappelé mais
en amont tout de même les trois grands
facteurs qui dégradent la santé de la
population notre pays le tabac l'alcool
et la pollution de l'air doivent faire
l'objet de politique de prévention forte
sur le tabac on a plutôt un
sentiment qu'après les mesures des
années tourenes et Busin bah il y a plus
grand-chose qui est fait pour lutter
contre le tabagisme et sur
l'alcool on a tous constaté que la la
dernière campagne de
prévention ne porte aucun message de
réduction de la consommation c'est
inédit et il faut pas se masquer
derrière la réduction des risques pour
nous dire mais si c'est formidable buvez
de l'eau quand vous buvez de l'alcool et
voilà vous réduirez les risques il n'y a
aucun message de réduction de la
consommation comment est-ce que
l'assurance
maladie se positionne face à ces
campagnes maintenant et à cette
politique qui devient euh bah difficile
à cner je vous
remercie merci beaucoup maintenant je
donne la parole à Justine guidez
oui merci président la fusion de la
carte Vitale avec la nouvelle carte
nationale d'identité mesure phare du
nouveau plan de lutte contre les fraudes
puisqu'on parlait de fraude tout à
l'heure aux finances publiques soulève
pourtant plusieurs interrogations tant
sur sa mise en œuvre technique que sur
sa protection des données pourtant déjà
adopté par plusieurs pays européens dont
la Suède le Portugal ou la Belgique
cette carte d'identité électronique
hybride permettrait pourtant de
renforcer des contrôles afin de résorber
les fraudes aux prestations sociales
comment comment avance-t-on dans en
France Merci la parole à veréronique
Guillotin
oui merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
déjà une une inquiétude effectivement ce
sont les négociations qui sont à venir
avec les les médecins notamment et on on
entend et enfin on sait qu'il va y avoir
donc un un mouvement de grève important
on entend effectivement sur les
territoires d'autres d'autres sujets
d'inquiétude moi je voudrais avoir si
vous avez quelques chiffres à nous
donner concernant les les j'allais dire
les menaces enfin les les risques en
tout cas de de déconventionnement de
certains médecins moi sur mon territoire
j'en ai quelques-uns qui sont effectifs
minoritaires certes mais déjà
déconventionnés et le mouvement de de de
de refus en fait de de s'engager de
manière obligatoire dans des CPTs avec
entre guillemets la la demande et
peut-être le fait que certains se
désengagent déjà des CPTs quel est votre
bon quelques chiffres déjà et puis quel
est votre état d'esprit sur ces
sujets-là en avant en avance des des
négociations je je crois qu'on fera pas
on peut tout dire que les médecins sont
corporatistes voilà je pense que chaque
profession l'IT ce que je pense par
contre c'est qu'on a peu de médecins le
le la désartification en tout cas
l'accès aux soins est difficile pour
pour nos concitoyens et je crois qu'on
ne pourra quand même pas faire contre
nos professions médicales mais bien avec
deux petites questions très technique il
y a un rapport qui a été publié sur les
déserts diagnostiques alors je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez si vous en pensez
quelque chose et les proposition euh
encore peut-être plus simplement sur les
prothèses auditives qui sont remboursées
par la CQ avec un part de de
remboursement sur les piles enfin les
les prothèses auditives rechargeables
vous parlez de de de transition
écologique et en tout cas de de
d'attitude correcte de la santé
vis-à-vis de l'environnement est-ce
qu'il est prévu d'une évolution vers des
prothèses auditives remboursées
rechargeables et enfin très généralement
voilà on a la France met beaucoup
d'argent dans la santé on met 11 % de
notre PIB quand même c'est un des pays
qui mettons le plus d'argent et on voit
que effectivement les résultats sur le
terrain on peut regarder les rapports
enfin voilà on quand on v V sur les
territoires on le sait on voit bien que
notre système de santé pour moi est à
bout de souffle je je suis pas convaincu
je sais pas si ça appelle répon he moi
je suis pas convaincu que ce soit par
des mesures alors il faut bien
évidemment contrôler les dépenses c'est
votre rôle je crois qu'il faut il faut
le faire faut pas de dépens inutile et
il faut de l'efficience par contre je
pense qu'on a quand même un système de
santé et une organisation de soins qui
effectivement à bout de souffle et je ne
suis pas convaincu que de d'année en
année on améliorera la situation si on
n'est pas plus convaincu d'y aller en en
profondeur très bien Monsieur le
Directeur je vous laisse déjà répondre à
ces premières questions oui tout à fait
merci beaucoup sur le le covid long ça
fait effectivement partie des sujets que
sur lequel nous nous nous travaillons
pourquoi je dis nous sommes en train
puisque bon à la fois pour ce qui est de
l'assurance maladie nous nous nous nous
assurons que dès lors qu'un assuré euh
souffrirait d'un covid long et qui se
traduirait dans sa prise en charge par
des éléments qui justifier dirait
l'attribution d'une al d' 100 % au titre
de ce qu'on appelle l'AL 31 le covid l
n'est pas dans la liste des des AL mais
dès lors que les critères de de ce qu'on
appelle l'ALD 31 hors liste sont réunis
parce que il a des soins chronique
important coûteux et durable alors nous
évidemment nous nous enclenchons le
processus de reconnaissance première
élément deuxième élément nous
travaillons avec les agences régionales
de santé et dans le casadre d'une
mission qui a été confiée au médecin
conseil national de l'Assurance Maladie
Dominique Martin à la structuration et
c'est presque ça le plus important je
dirais de de de filièr de prise en
charge qui permett de s'assurer de la
coordination des acteurs dans le
repérage de ce phénomène de covid long
et dans des mécanismes de prise en
charge articulé entre la ville et
l'hôpital ça c'est un travail qui s'est
engagé depuis plusieurs mois et puis
évidemment nous sommes en relation
étroite avec avec santé publi France et
le ministère de la Santé vous savez que
les travaux épidémiologiques et
d'appréhension du phénomène du covid
long continuer à progresser pour mieux
cerner le le l'importance de ce
phénomène sa qualification et et les
conditions de prise en charge donc c'est
un domaine qui est encore évolutif mais
sur lequel on est extrêmement
impliqué monsieur le sénateur jumier
bien bien pris note de votre
interpellation sur la qualité de la
gestion de la sécurité sociale vous vous
vous vous vous vous mesurit qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose entre entre 2017 et
2023 qu'en 2019 en effet les
perspectives fin de l'assurance maladie
était à l'équilibre mais je crois qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose qui a entraîné
un déficit de 30 milliards d'euros qui
est en effet mécaniquement difficile à à
résorber je ne crois pas que ce soit le
signe d'une d'une mauvaise gestion au
contraire c'est le signe d'une attention
à un système d'assurance maladie qui je
crois ne souffrirait mal d'un d'une
purge économique qui viserait simplement
à le à le remettre à l'équilibre donc
mais mais je pense pense que vous
serez d'accord avec
ça les indicateurs de santé que vous
avez équé sont évidemment des points de
vigilance très
important nous restons tout de même si
on regarde les 10 dernières années sur
une progression de l'espérance de vie
pour les femmes comme pour les hommes
donc je pense que c'est à à intégrer
pour ce qui est de l'Assurance Maladie
notre notre investissement il est il est
d'abord sur ce sujets là sur les les
sujets de prévention et si nous sommes
des acteurs notamment de la prévention
du du de de l'usage du tabac avec tout
ce que nous faisons sur l'accompagnement
des assurés le mois sans tabac les
applications que nous mettons à
disposition euh nous sommes aussi
extrêmement investis et nous allons être
de plus en plus investis sur d'autres
thématiques de prévention d'avantage
d'avantage secondairire je pense à la
reprise euh des invitations sur les
dépistages organisés des cancers nous
allons mettre en place tout une logique
euh d'invitation de relance d'aller ver
euh qui qui a montré je crois ses
résultats sur les tests et sur la
vaccination covid nous allons nous
impliquer sur les les bilans de
prévention aux ascl de la vie le
évidemment l'accompagnement des
programmes de vaccination HPV donc de ce
point de vue-là la la la meilleure
réponse en tout cas sur
le les indicateurs de santé c'est
l'investissement de l'Assurance Maladie
renforcé en matière de la de prévention
la la convention d'objectif et de
gestion que nous avons signé avec l'État
fait de la prévention un des six axes
stratégique de de l'Assurance Maladie
vous m'interrogez sur les lien entre
pertinence et financierisation euh et je
crois que c'est un débat important je je
je me permets de souligner que que que
pas toute seule mais l'assurance maladie
a été un des acteurs ces derniers mois
qui a mis en avant euh la préoccupation
sur ce sujet de la financiarisation
encore une fois dans le rapport chargé
produit au vu de ce qui se passe sur la
biologie au vu de ce qui est en train de
se passer potentiellement sur la
radiologie en effet de ce point de
vue-là là je je vous indique que nous
travaillons avec les les radiologues euh
sur un nouveau protocole pluriannuel
autour de la pertinence de la radiologie
qui s'intégrera aussi dans les
discussions avec les médecins puisque
derrière cette pertinence il y a aussi
évidemment la la prescription mais nous
voulons euh voilà euh avancer là
là-dessus et nous confirmons nos nos
propositions euh en matière de
financierisation pour alors ça ça n'a
l'air d'être que de la gouvernance mais
si déjà nous réunissons l'ensemble des
parties prenantes c'est pas nous he
c'est l'état autour de de ce cette
thématique autour d'un observatoire et
puis de mettre en place aussi une
mission de contrôle puisque nous
considérons que la réglementation semble
être parfois contourné ce sera déjà
important donc je je je ne doute pas que
les des évolutions vont voir le jour sur
ce sujet qui est en effet très très
important euh madame guidz vous
m'interrogez sur la carte vitale et la
la carte d'identité
peut-être je me permets de
partager le travail qui a été mené par
les inspections générales des affaires
sociales et de des finances il y a
quelques mois qui a fait un point très
approfondi et qui a montré
mais je ne fais
que rapporter ce qu'ils ont
écrit le caractère inopportun d'une
carte vitale biométrique je crois que
c'était utile que euh un travail très
approfondi et indépendant soit mené pour
montrer euh l'inefficacité d'un tel
projet
euh maintenant la question de de savoir
si la la carte d'identité d'identité
pourrait porter euh le le numéro sécité
social le nire et pourrait permettre de
faire converger ces ces deux cartes euh
le ministre le le précédent ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Atal avait
annoncé une une mission d'inspection sur
ce sujet pour instruire cette hypothèse
euh je crois que cette mission est en en
passe d'être lancée et donc nous y
participerons pour ce qui est de
l'assurance maladie nous sommes de notre
côté mobilisés d'ailleurs le le rapport
des inspections soulignit l'importance
et la pertinence de ce projet sur le
déploiement du projet qu'on appelle apcv
c'est-à-dire la dématérialisation de la
carte Vitale c'est-à-dire mettre la
carte Vitale sur votre smartphone euh
les les les tests sont en cours on a
déjà plusieurs dizaines de
milliers
de de personnes qui testent cette carte
Vitale sur votre smartphone avec un
mécanisme sécurisé
d'enrôlement et donc qui permettra de
participer à la sécurisation de nos
process d'identification euh madame
Guillotin vous m'interrogez sur la la
négociation avec les médecins euh
peut-être juste sur les
déconventionnements euh aujourd'hui les
les chiffres sont très limité puisque
depuis le début de l'année il y a eu
44 médecins généralistes qui se sont
déconventionnés euh alors c'est 44 de
trop si vous me permettez l'expression
puisque c'est une décision que je
regrette mais à rapporter au un peu
moins de 50000 médecins généralistes
donc nous restons sur un phénomè domain
très ponctuel et c'est heureux je crois
que l'immense majorité des médecins
quelle que soit la nature de leur
revendication s'incrivent dans une
convention avec l'assurance maladieque
qui permet de prendre en charge les
soins de leurs patients et de financer
leur activité et donc je je pense que
c'est quelque chose de positif sur les
les prothèses auditives pardon les
CPTs
ah tout
euh je crois que vous aurez eu l'ion
vous aurez l'occasion dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines de
d'examiner ce sujet ce que je ce que
donc voilà ce que je ce que je peux en
tout cas apporter c'est que les CPTs
sont en train de s'inscrire vraiment
dans les dans les territoires à des
degrés de maturité différent on a
dépassé au début de l'année plus de la
moitié de la population couverte par des
CPTs on sera à des niveaux élevés à la
fin de l'année et donc quels sont les
les les leviers pour euh voilà favoriser
euh l'implication des des professionnels
de santé dansc
CPTs je crois que voilà c'est le la
formule qui avait été trouvée à
l'assemblée était assez équilibré mais
j'imagine que que que que le que le
Sénat se se prononcera là-dessus je sais
dans les dans les prochaines semaines
euh sur les prothèses auditives et
rechargeables si je laisserai monsieur
de la ganerie vous apportez cette
précision qui m étrang alors il y a une
prise en charge des prothèses auditives
par l'Assurance Maladie rechargeable
simplement dans le panier 100 % santé on
peut pe avoir des difficultés à trouver
euh des prothèses auditives
rechargeables après je pense que c'est
aussi une transition à menener parce que
pour avoir assisté à des séances
d'appareillage c'est vrai qu'il y a
aussi des personnes âgées qui ne se
sentent pas d'avoir un appareil
rechargeable qui F les piles bon voilà
mais en tout cas ça peut faire partie
d'une transition du panier 100 % santé
ou d'une évolution du panier 100 % santé
d'avoir dans le cahier des charges comme
il y a différents critères technique
d'avoir également le sujet rechargeable
en
effet bien merci bien je donne la parole
maintenant à Daniel
Chassin merci Monsieur le le Président
Monsieur le Directeur euh donc bah
écoutez je je me réjouis que le
l'assurance maladie bien est moins de de
déficit c'est vrai que vous avez eu à
faire avec le covid hein vous l'avez
rappelé et puis le séure de la santé qui
a quand même apporté des satisfactions
personnel on peut dire c'est le
rattrapage mais enfin ça fait quand même
à peu près 300 € par par aide soignante
et par mois euh donc je pense que
c'était un progrès mais effectivement on
a intérêt à ce que toutes les branche de
la sécurité sociale arrive en équilibre
parce que c'est quand même la colonne
vertébrale de notre démocratie alors euh
vous avez proposé une maîtrise des
dépenses de santé avec les transports
partagés les antibiotiques trotes et
puis aussi cisti qui peuvent être
traités par les pharmaciens je pense une
bonne chose comme l'arrêt de travail
avec les téléconsultations pas plus de 3
jours et enfin la prévention avec les
vaccinations sur les papilovirus
papinomavirus et enfin aussi ce qui est
important c'est que les pharmaciens et
et les médecins et les infirmiers
puissent puisse se vacciner tout comme
la détection effectivement des des
autistes alors je souhaite que la lutte
contre la fraude bien soit encore
anticipée mais je voudrais poser trois
questions que se posent beaucoup nos
concitoyens lutte contre la pénurie de
médicament euh ça devient quand même
très difficile alors que dans les autres
pays voisins on n pas ce problème et
aussi pourquoi pas de substitution du
médicament par le pharmacien le
pharmacien est obligé de téléphoner au
médecin pour savoir s'il peut je pense
que le pharmacien est apte de savoir
s'il peut substituer le le médicament
enfin 2è question les lits d'aval aux
urgences V qu'on voit souvent beaucoup
de brancards au aux urgences avec des
gens qui sont là parce que ils vont pas
repartir chez eux ils vont rester à
l'hôpital mais on trouve pas de lit et
donc il y a un problème de de
d'augmentation nécessaire de lit d'aval
des urgences avec bien sûr en amont une
formation des infirmières et et des et
des AES soignantes 3ème question j'ai lu
effectivement dans le projet de de
presse l'augmentation des personnels en
épad mais c'est très peu le président de
la République avait parlé de 50000 an
emploi euh là c'est 6000 emplois je
rappelle qu'il y a près de 8000 EPAD ça
fait moins d'emploi moins d'un emploi
par EPAD alors qu'on a une amentation
très très importante de la de la
dépendance en éepad et comment euh
comptez-vous mettre en place l'embauche
des proposer l'embauche au moins de
50000 emplois euh dans le Médico-Social
pour les personnes âgées je pense ça
c'est très important pour le domicile et
pour l'EPAD et enfin en épad vous avez
euh une expérimentation de la prise en
charge de la
branche par la branche autonomie et la
fusion du budget soins dépendance et je
pense que ça ça me paraît très important
à condition de pouvoir que le Conseil
départemental n'est pas à participer
puisqu'il aura beaucoup à participer
pour permettre le domiciliaire
l'augmentation de la présence
domiciliaire des des personnes âgées à
domicile donc problème si vous voulez de
prise en charge par l'Assurance Maladie
de la dépendance et des soins enfin
juste 4è question très rapidement si
vous voulez on a au niveau optique euh
les complémentaires ont des réseaux et
remboursent uniquement si vous voulez si
vous êtes dans le réseau c'est-à-dire
que vous avez des personnes qui sont
obligé de faire 50 km pour trouver un
opticien qui est dans le réseau quand
est-ce que cela va se terminer merci
très bien je donne la parole à nadias le
goût
ou merci monsieur le Président euh je
voulais faire un petit focus sur une
profession sur laquelle on articule
beaucoup de choses qui est la profession
des infirmiers alors particulièrement en
ville comme on compte beaucoup sur eux
pour libérer du temps médical maintenant
il y a plusieurs mécanismes dispositifs
il y a les IPA il y a les infirmières à
all les infirmiers de soins primaires en
équipe et cetera je do en passer est-ce
que vous pensez pas qu'en multipliant
les dispositifs on risque de faire
perdre un peu de lisibilité à à tout ça
et puis aussi sur le problème de la
fraude alors on est tous d'accord mais
c'est quand même une profession pour
laquelle maintenant la tarification est
devenue d'une telle complexité bon je
sais que c'est le résultat aussi des
négociations conventionnelles mais
malgré tout peut-être qu'il faut
commencer par faire la pédagogie c'est
des des professionnels qui sont épuisés
bien souvent qui font un travail énorme
on en a extrêmement besoin et avant de
leur tomber dessus à bras raccourci il
faudrait commencer par faire peut-être
un peu plus de pédagogie parce que moi
j'ai eu des remontées d'infirmiers sur
le terrain qui qui demande qui crée un
petit peu grass bon euh 2è question
concernant la la la 4e année de
spécialité en médecine générale donc qui
a été votée je pense queelle devrait se
mettre en place je voulais savoir si la
question de la rémunération de ces
fameux docteurs junior avaient été
tranché et si dans le budget tout ça
représentait un était bien prévu enfin
est qui bien une ligne budgétaire pour
nos docteurs juniors qui feront leur 4e
année en en en territoire sous-doté et
puis dernière question qui n'est pas
budgétaire mais qui est très importante
pour nous aussi pour qui l'accès aux
soins est vraiment prioritaire au sens
large et en particulier pour les soins
dentaires je voulais savoir si le la
révision du zonage dentaire allait
vraiment se faire de toute urgence parce
qu'il y a manifestement un décalage
entre la réalité de terrain et le et le
et le zonage si bien que ça ça ralenti
ça freine
certaines installations de de praticiens
et on aurait besoin de cette révision de
zonage de façon très très urgente merci
merci bien
jean-marieberg merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Directeur ça ne vous étonnera pas je
vais vous poser quelques questions
concernant la fraude et et et je
reviendrai aussi sur la question de la
pertinence des soins qu'a évoqué tout à
l'heure Bernard jaumier sur la fraude
tout d'abord je je suis comme
vous rassuré de voir que vous augmentez
les montants détectés et
stoppés 316 millions si j'ai bien noté
380 fléchés pour
2023 500 millions en
2024 mais ça représente que 02 % des 250
milliards de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie 02 %
c'est très faible notamment par rapport
au aux
estimations et je vais en venir aux
estimations que vous estime enfin que
vous chiffrez à entre 2 et demi et 6,8 %
suivant les
profession ce qui se monte évidemment à
ce moment-là des chiffres dehors de 5 à
milliards de
fraude donc on est très loin du compte
alors je voudrais savoir où vous en êtes
sur les
estimations moi j'ai calculé avec les
chiffres que vous avez fournis dans la
note qui nous a été transmise qui a à
peu près 25
milliards de montant de dépenses qui ont
été
détecter estimer plus exactement évaluer
alors quand pourrezvous est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quand vous en aurez
terminé avec ces
estimations
et
deè question si vous voulez sur la
pertinence vous avez répondu sur la
radiologie mais c'est pas que la
radiologie qui est effectivement
concerné tout à l'heure Bernard jomi
rappelé le chiffre qu'a évoqué madame
Buzin mais qui reprend effectivement les
estimations de l'OCDE c'est 20 à 25 % de
soins ou d'actes redondant ou
inuti alors je trouve que on on est très
faible dans l'action en ce qui concerne
et ça ne concerne pas que l'assurance
maladie je sais que la Haute Autorité de
Santé travaille sur ce sujet je trouve
que c'est lent alors qu'il y a là une
mine considérable d'économie quand on
voit les besoins effectivement de
l'assurance maladie et surtout les les
les déficits il y a là une source
d'économie
considérable alors question corollaire
où en est-on de l'ouverture du nombre
d'ouverture de mon Espace Santé qui
remplace le DMP merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Directeur merci
Olivier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général merci pour
la clarté de vos propos même si parfois
on avait l'impression en vous écoutant
que c'était une forme de tout va pour le
mieux dans le meilleur des membresibles
hein
euh j'ai je reviens il y a beaucoup de
questions qui ont été posées je reviens
sur cette affaire de financiarisation et
d'ailleurs un matin de à la mi-juillet
quand on est en campagne électorale on
fait beaucoup de voitures on a enfilé la
robe de Bur et vous étiez sur une radio
périphérique matinale et vous aviez
lancé une alerte sur la
financiarisation de de la santé et moi
je ne me positionne pas du point de vue
de de l'éthique encore que c'est un vrai
sujet mais de la gravité est-ce que ça
vient pas heurter tout notre système de
santé son organisation et sa structure
parce que les pères fondateurs quand ils
ont conçu la sécurité sociale avec
liberté d'installation libre choix du
médecin libre prescription ils l'ont
fait avec un principe qui était celui
d'une gestion sur le terrain de bon père
ou de bonne mère de famille une pratique
un peu libérale comme on la connaissait
à l'ancienne et au fond cette question
de financiarisation elle vient
totalement entrechoquer
heurter notre organisation et notre
système de santé et et il me semble que
par rapport à à ce phénomène on lutte un
peu et c'est c'est la question que je
vais vous poser votre vision quels sont
les outils de régulation on lutte un peu
avec des arcs et des flèches en quelque
sorte par rapport à à quelque chose qui
me semble extrêmement lourd et moi
j'appartiens à une famille de pensé qui
ne voudrait pas que ça se dégrade à tel
point que à un moment donné on a plus
d'autre choix que la nationalisation voz
je je je pense que si on n'est pas en
capacité ceux qui pensent que c'est né
la diversité la compétition la pratique
libérale de réguler et et d'avoir une
des des outils extrêmement fortes à ce
moment-là évidemment certains ou
certaines à juste titre d'ailleurs
seront tentés de dire bah il y a pas
d'autre possibilité que de remettre en
cause ce système de santé et de proposer
ce que je ne veux pas une
nationalisation donc ma ma question
c'est quel quel quel outil de de
régulation assez fort voyez-vous par
rapport à ce phénomène parce que je vous
ai bien écouté ce matin-là et vous avez
dit à un moment donné on n pas vu venir
le la financierisation de la biologie on
n pas vu venir c'est tout de même
embêtant donc la question que je pose
c'est comment faites-vous maintenant
pour voir venir et comment faites-vous
pour imaginer assez rapidement parce que
ça va arriver dans des tas d'autres
secteurs une régulation efficace et
efficiente je vous remercie merci bien
fré
plusard oui merci Monsieur le le
président et merci Monsieur le Directeur
Général alors je vais être un peu dans
dans dans la dans la lignée de de mon
collègue Olivier h et et peut-être sur
une question qui qui de porté beaucoup
plus général d'abord constater quand
même que depuis 2019 nous avons
quasiment plus aucun projet de loi aucun
projet de loi porté par le gouvernement
depuis 2019 certes la crise sanitaire
est au milieu mais on peut quand même
s'interroger sur cette absence de de
stratégie de santé à moyen long terme
ensuite on a finalement des PLFSS qui
font presque office 2 avec permettez-moi
de lire alors j'étais pas dans la même
voiture qu'Olivier h quand je faisais ma
campagne mais j'ai j'ai entendu quand
même un certain nombre de mesures de
prévention qui été porté dans ce PLFSS
et je me suis dit on est horors sol
alors ces mesures ont tout un intérêt
j'ai pas de j'ai pas de sujet à
proprement parler là-dessus mais on est
presque horsol pourquoi parce que sur le
territoire on constate quoi on constate
qu'on a quasiment plus un service
d'urgence qui est ouvert on constate que
on a quasiment un certain nombre de
personnes qui ne sont pas dans la
prévention mais qui ne savent même plus
comment se soigner parce qu'elles n'ont
plus de médecins libéraux parce qu'elles
ne trouvent plus de dentiste parce
qu'elle ne trouve plus les
professionnels sur le territoire on
constate qu'on a des collectivités qui
essayent de trouver des solutions sur
une compétence régalienne de l'État sur
lequel nous estimons j'estime que nous
ne sommes pas au rendez-vous alors je je
regarde quand même ce pfss avec un
certain nombre de d'inquiétude je je
vous le dis je pense que nous décrochons
encore et et la question que je j'ai
envie de vous poser parce
qu'effectivement j'entends bien qu'on
ait des mesures de d'économie à faire
sur ce spfss mais un est-ce qu'on en a
vraiment pour notre argent et est-ce
qu'on a pas intérêt à tout reposer du
début jusqu'à la fin sur nos enjeux de
santé merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur je vous laisse répondre déjà à
cette salve de question
peut-être une réponse d'abord un tout
petit peu transversale
pour peut-être dissiper une ambigué nous
sommes bien placés à l'Assurance Maladie
pour de par la notre réseau territorial
pour mesurer les tensions qui existent
dans le système de santé les difficultés
de l'accès aux soins et si vous avez
déduit de mon propos introductif que
tout allait bien ça n'est pas le cas
mais ce qui justifie surtout qu'on
agisse et si nous déployons depuis le
début de l'année mais dans le le
droitfil de ce qu'on avait déjà commencé
à faire un plan d'action sur trouver un
médecin traitant pour les patients en al
qui n'en nont pas c'est bien parce que
nous avons identifié ce sujet pas tout
seul euh comme un sujet majeur euh il y
avait 600000 patients nd son médecins
traitant début 22 700000 début 23 et si
nous ne faisons rien il y en aura 800000
à la fin de l'année donc nous nous
mobilisons nous mobilisons les médecins
les CPTs les maisons de santé les
équipes pluridisciplinaires les centres
de santé pour répondre à ces sujetsl
pourquoi nous voulons recruter ou que
les médecins plutôt recrutent 10000
assistants médicaux c'est parce que que
auprès des cabinets parce que nous
pensons que ça peut changer la donne
substantiellement pour redonner au
médecin traitant une capacité à prendre
des patients donc oui la situation
étendue mais en même temps notre métier
mais c'est de trouver des solutions et
donc de mailler le territoire de CPTs de
faire plus de santé plus d'assistants
médicaux de trouver un médecin traitant
pour les patients NLD et je crois pas
pardon madame la sénatrice que les
mesures du PLFSS sur la prévention soit
hors sol je crois pas excusez-moi de le
dire un peu directement mais que ce soit
hors sol de vacciner les les gamins de
5e sur HPV je pense que c'est des
mesures très importantes et qui vont
permettre d'améliorer l'état de santé de
nos
concitoyens sur
euh si je reprends dans l'ordre mon
sénateur Chassin sur la lutte contre la
la la pénurie oui le le les pharmaciens
sont des acteurs importants le les
sujets de substitution sont quand même
des sujets délicats sur lequel ça ne se
fait que dans le cadre de protocole
validé par la NSM l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament donc
on est on se situe dans ce dans ce cadre
là mais on souhaitera avec les médecins
et les pharmaciens voir comment nous
pouvons aller plus loin pour que les
pharmaciens soient encore davantage des
acteurs clés dans le le bon usage du
médicament sur les lit d'aval alors
c'est c'est c'est moins dans dans le
champ de compétence de l'assurance
maladie je crains de vous faire la même
réponse sur les épades qui sont
maintenant très largement de la
compétence de la 5e branche de la
sécurité sociale de la de la CNSA euh de
ce point de vue-là la la fusion possible
des sections soinsépendant c'est
sûrement une simplification intéressante
pour ce qui est de l'assurance maladie
et pour répondre sur les lit d'aval nous
sommes engagés dans le sujet de la
l'accompagnement la sortie
d'hospitalisation avec nos programmes
qu'on appelle Prado d'accompagnement de
la sortie de de l'hôpital on on le fait
notamment sur l'insuffisance cardiaque
et et ça se déploie plus largement et
c'est quelque chose qu'on veut faire
plus systématiquement même si c'est une
charge assez lourde que d'organiser
cette sortie euh d'hôpital quand c'est
euh nécessaire de le faire
euh madame
euh la sénatrice groupe sur les sur les
infirmières
euh sur la complexité de la nomenclature
euh et alors très clairement on on
partage le fait que mais vous l'avez dit
la nomenclature est complexe elle n'est
pas que le fruit de l'imagination
fertile de l'assurance maladie elle est
aussi le fruit de discussion avec les
professionnels de santé mais euh voilà
quand on forme un professionnel de santé
on forme d'abord à soigner et et donc
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons engagé depuis maintenant presque 2
ans un programme systématique
systématique d'accompagnement des
infirmiers et des infirmières qui
s'installent en libéral euh et qui euh
voilà ont un accompagnement euh renforcé
dès l'installation à la à la
l'appropriation de la nomenclature et
ensuite euh nous venons les contrôler 4
mois après euh sur un contrôle à blanc
pédagogique et puis 12 mois après nous
revenons donc euh il y a un peu trop
encore même si ça fait pour tirer tous
les enseignements on est en train de
faire évoluer le programme mais très
clairement on s'engage dans la
prévention je dirais de la et
l'accompagnement des infirmiers pour
pouvoir les les accompagner vous aviez
posé une première question sur les
infirmiers mais du coup j'ai mal noté
rémunération des docteurs juniors et la
révision oui j'ai noté oui oui sur les
docteurs juniors les travaux se sont
engagés sur la base des recommandations
de la mission qui des quatre
personnalités qualifiées que que
François Brown avait et avec Sylvie
rotaillot avait mobilisé pour proposer
l'idée c'est d'avoir une rémunération à
la fois attractive pour inciter
l'installation et le choix de ce de ces
posts de docteur junior encore plus
attractif dans les zones Soudans euh les
travaux se poursuivent on est on est
quand même sur un une échéance 2026 donc
c'est c'est c'est important mais euh
voilà le comme c'est les les les les
nouveaux qui vont rentrer dans cette
filière qui vont sortir partir en 2036
on a un peu de temps pour se préparer et
sur le zonage dentaire sur le zonage
dentaire donc on on a signé avec les les
dentistes libéraux au mois de juillet
une nouvelle convention qui prévoit un
renforcement des mesures incitative dans
les zones dans les zones sousdanses et
puis une régulation dans les zones
surdanses puisque ou plutôt pardon dans
les zones non prioritaires comme on les
appelle dans la convention avec le
principe du un pour un dans ces zones
non prioritaires le les dentistes
libéraux ou les centres de santé
dentaire et notamment leurs salariés
dentistes ne pourront s'installer ou
être embauchés que si un dentiste s'en
va donc c'est le même pour donc oui le
zonage va être remis à jour le le
cadrage national va être fait d'ici la
fin de l'année ou tout début de l'année
prochaine et pour un zonage qui sera
refait par les ARS dans le courant de
l'année 2024 sachant que les mesures
elles vont plutôt intervenir 1er janvier
2025 donc on a un an pour se préparer je
sais qu'il y a urgence mais c'est des
travaux qui sont quand même assez lourds
et et qu'on a besoin de de
préparer monsieur le sénateur van
lurenberg euh bien noter votre attention
continue et renforcé sur la lutte contre
la fraude
euh
d'abord VO partager que on est sur une
pente ascendante très significative
puisque nous
sommes passés de d'un peu plus de 200
million d'euros à près de 380 en 2023 et
et 500 en 2024 je veux d'abord vous
rassurer sur un point euh nous ne
souhaitons pas nous arrêter là enfin
d'abord il faut faire les choses dans
l'ordre atteindre les objectifs qu'on
s'est fixés en 2023224 c'est déjà le
premier point mais on ne s'arrêtera pas
au 500 millions en 2024 et donc on se
fixera des objectifs plus élevés au-delà
de 2024 parce que vous l'avez
pointé nous faisons face à des
phénomènes qui représentent à chaque
fois quelques pour et c'est d' une
évaluation que nous réalisons sujet par
sujet vous le savez mais quelques pour
de 250 milliards d'euros ça fait en
effet potentiellement des montants
encore plus importants euh sur
l'évaluation vous le savez nous nous
continuons hein nous avons présenté la
semaine dernière les résultats sur trois
nouvelles professions les massur kinési
thérapeutes les chirurgiens dentistes
libéraux les spécialistes libéraux et
nous nous poursuivons les travaux pour
que d'ici la fin de 23 et le début de
l'année 2024 nous ayons traité les
fournisseurs de LPP des dispositifs méd
les laboratoires de biologie les rentes
accidents du travail maladie
professionnell les pensions d'invalidité
et les établissements de santé le sujet
établissement de santé est un peu
particulier puisque compte tenu du covid
de la garantie de financement du système
de maintien de financement au travers du
SMA la problématique de l'évaluation
fraude a été rendue plus complexe mais
donc nous continuons donc pour vous
répondre directement nous aurons terminé
ce premier cycle au premier semestre
2024 de déévaluation de la fraude et qui
à chaque fois génère des plan d'action
dédié en face de ces travaux
d'évaluation et bien sûr nous
collaborons nous nous contribuerons
étroitement aux travaux du Conseil de
l'évaluation de des fraudes qui a été
installé par le ministre Thomas kaznav
hier matin sur mon espace santé les
derniers chiffres que je peux vous
communiquer c'est que plus de 9,6
millions de personnes ont
activé activer leur espace santé vous
savez que c'est le principe de l'OP
l'optout c'est-à-dire que seulement peu
moins de 2 % des assuré se sont opposé
donc leur pour 98 % leur espace santé
est opérationnel mais il est activé
aujourd'hui pour 9,6 millions nous avons
relancé une campagne d'information et de
communication au mois de septembre que
vous avez peut-être vu sur euh vos
écrans de de télévision ou sur les
réseaux numériques ou sur euh différents
supports et ça a permis de relancer une
campagne d'activation en tout cas des
démarches d'activation sur nos auprès de
nous assurer donc nous sommes confiants
que cette dynamique va se poursuivre et
euh et elle fait écho à la dynamique
importante de de d'alimentation euh de
mon Espace Santé le la délégation du
numérique en santé a fait un point il y
a une quinzaine de jours qui montrait
les courbes très significativement
exponentiell de l'alimentation de de mon
Espace Santé du DMP donc ça va dans le
bon
sens Monsieur H vous m'interrogez sur la
financiarisation
euh euh est-ce que on préfère un système
de santé uniquement géré par des
des bons pères de famille pour reprendre
votre expression la la la la réponse est
oui après je je je pense que mes votre
propos liencité d'ailleurs notre système
de santé depuis
longtemps comment dirais-je s'appuie sur
des acteurs privés non lucratifs privés
lucratif et public c'est sa force c'est
cette complémentarité cette concurrence
parfois saine qui fait que je crois que
même si la situation est difficile et de
ce point de vue-là je nous invite
toujours à à regarder ce qui se passe
chez nos voisins les pénuries de
médicaments existent aussi chez nos
voisins y compris même chez des pays qui
ont des prix de médicaments les plus
élevés au monde et quand je dialogue
avec mes homologues belges ou allemands
je l'ai fait régulièrement ils font face
à aux mêmes difficultés de de de de
pénuriie en matière de professionnel de
santé donc et je vous invite à regarder
comment les Allemands définissent un
désert médical ils ont pas exactement la
même définition que nous euh s'agissant
voilà après une fois qu'on a dit ça sur
la financiarisation on a besoin de
capitaux d'investissement aussi Dieu
sait que je me suis un peu battu mais
pacifiquement avec nos amis biologistes
dans les négociations mais la réalité
est que si les les laboratoires privés
de biologie n'avaient pas investi
massivement pour dans des machines pour
faire plusieurs centaines de milliers de
tests voir plusieurs millions par jour
euh nous aurions eu un peu de mal à
faire face aux besoins de tests pendant
le covid donc euh on est aussi dans des
secteur et la radiologie c'est pareil et
d'autres domaines dans lequel il y a
besoin de capitaux euh ces capitaux ont
besoin être régulé une des raisons pour
lesquell la financiarisation s'est
installée aussi c'est que les rendements
étaient trop élevés et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons baissé
les tarifs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons aussi signé avec les
biologistes un accord pluriannuel
ambitieux qui nous amènera à agir sur la
pertinence de la biologie mais aussi à
ajuster les tarifs donc à continuer à
avoir des secteurs qui sont
rémunérateurs mais aussi dans des
conditions accepable
euh voilà monsieur le Président merci
bien alors il reste h intervenants ah
oui je vous demande vraiment d'être très
concis dans vos questions sinon vous
poserez les questions vous n'aurez pas
les réponses nous n'aurons pas le temps
d'accord donc je vous demande vraiment
d'être concis les un les autres pour vos
questions je commence par Cline
Brulin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général vous avez
évoqué longame d'une manière plutôt
positive puisque vous avez indiqué qu'il
était plus élevé que l'inflation dont
vous AAZ dit on aimerait vous croire
qu'elle allait redescendre si on en
croit le contexte international qu'
connait aujourd'hui je dirais que rien
n'est moins sûr et que de toute façon ça
n'empêche pas un certain nombre
d'acteurs de la santé d'être très
inquiet de ce montant de long d'AM je
pense notamment au secteur hospitalier
euh dont on connaît l'état d'ors et déjà
et un certain nombre de difficultés ont
été évoquées par nos collègues et
j'ajouteraiis
que cela risque de se percuté avec une
réforme du mode de financement et
notamment une une moindre part de la T2A
dans le financement des des hôpitaux et
donc dans quelle mesure tout cela ne va
pas accroître les difficulté on est un
certain nombre à être favorable à ce que
la T2A prenne une part moins importante
voire pas importante du tout dans le
financement des hôpitaux mais la
conjonction de ce faible niveau de long
d'â et de cette réforme peut être assez
inquiétante vous avez évoqué le COG avec
le fait que vous rendiez selon
l'expression consacrée 700 postes après
en avoir déjà rendu plus de 20 %
je et vous avez dit alors tout ça c'est
parfaitement juste bien évidemment mais
vous avez dit que en gros le maillage et
le service rendu sur le terrain n avait
pas été impacté ça n'est pas
permettez-moi de vous le dire tout à
fait le ressenti que nous avons sur le
terrain et si j'en crois les mou que
j'ai vu sur les visages d'un certain
nombre de nos collègs ce sentiment est
assez partagé je le dis comme un
argument euh pour défendre euh votre
administration qui je crois ne peut pas
rendre davantage de postes en plus la
dématérialisation a des effets
extrêmement délétair sur un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens dernière
question monsieur le Président euh vous
avez évoqué les négociations et d'autres
collègues l'ont fait aussi avec les
médecins seule profession où elles n'ont
pas abouti
euh
quel enfin quelles sont les pistes pour
que d'éventuelles augmentations euh de
la tarification des médecins ne
n'impacte pas les patients et les
assurés qui sont dans un contexte de
pouvoir d'achat qu'on connaît et quelle
contrepartie peut-on envisager euh à une
rémunération plus importante des médecin
vous venez d'évoquer au sujet des
dentistes et du zonage un certain nombre
d'éléments de régulation modeste mais
quand même est-ce que ça ne serait pas
envisageable également dans les
négociations avec les médecins merci
très bien Pascal grunny
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
vais d'abord poser une une question en
relais avec ma ma collègue Marie-Pierre
Richer concernant la la branche
ATMP
et sur laquelle en fait il y a un
prélèvement qui augmente chaque année de
plus d'un milliard d'euros donc je
voudrais savoir si vous aviez avancé
justement pour la sous-déclaration l'an
dernier on nous avait dit que les
médecins allaient recevoir des éléments
pour les les aider et éviter ce
transfert brutal alors qu'on a besoin de
faire de la prévention dans les
entreprises
euh toujours sur le même domaine
médecine du du travail je voudrais
savoir où où on est du dossier
médical partagé et si ça va dans les
deux sens c'est-à-dire on a vu que le
dossier médical santé au travail
devait arriver dans le dossier médical
personne personnel avec bien sûr
l'accord de du patient mais ce serait
bien qu'il y ait aussi de l'autre côté
ça fait avancer à la fois sur la santé
la santé publique et la prévention et
sur les contrôles beaucoup de monde en
ont parlé moi je vais vous dire ce qui
revient je pense que donc il y a des
contrôles partout premièrement la
pédagogie bien sûr peut-être prendre des
cours avec les contrôleurs fiscaux qui
ont aujourd'hui beaucoup plus d'empathie
que les contrôleurs qui sont voyez chez
les médecins mais vous vous je viens du
monde de l'entreprise les contrôles
fiscaux j'en ai eu je peux vous dire
qu'il y a vraiment un vrai dialogue ce
qui n'est pas là et aussi l'adéquation
au territoire parce que en fait vous
vous faites vous envoyez des des des
contrôles euh en fonction souvent du
nombre de patients qui sont reçus et
comme on a de moins en moins en fait de
médecins ben moi je vais vous dire que
les médecins ils sont surchargés ils
font ils sont obligés d'en recevoir
énormément donc ça ce serait bien et
peut-être faire des contrôles des pseudo
centres de santé qui fleurissent au coin
de nos nos rues dans dans nos villes
merci Anil
louerou merci monsieur le Président ma
ma question porte sur les cabines de
consultation nous partageons tous le
constat d'un effondrement de notre
système de santé donc sur nos
territoirees plus de médecins traitant
plus de services d'urgence plus de
maternité report des chirurgies plus de
dentistes plus de plus de prévention
puisquon est octobre
dans mon département c'est un mois
d'attente pour obtenir une un
rendez-vous pour une mammographie donc
ma question et pourtant on voit fleurir
donc c cabine de téléconsultation en
2022 vous nous avez dit la nécessité de
trouver un statut pour les offreurs de
téléconsultation et pour les médecins
employés par ces plateformes avez-vous
avancé sur ce cahier des charges merci
merci Annesophie
romaniie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur quelques questions
sur le le burnout syndrome d'épuisement
qui a tendance à croître depuis
plusieurs années nous observons
plusieurs niveaux de Burnout et ce terme
pour autant est très usité je voulais
savoir s'il y avait des critères de
contrôle du burnout comment sont
contrôler ces ces burnout et combien
coûte aujourd'hui un burnout dans notre
société merci bien
unaminant ou merci monsieur le Président
euh c'est la le budget d'assurance
maladie c'est quand même un budget de
200 220 milliards il est normal qu'on
prenne le temps d'en
discuter je voudrais juste revenir 2
secondes Monsieur le Directeur ce que
vous avez dit sur la clause de
sauvegarde c'est quand même gênant
d'inciter à la mise en place des
génériques et ensuite de limiter cette
dépense de dé génériqu quelque part il y
a un problème là qu'il faudra régler et
dont nous reparlerons en séance je vrais
revenir 2 secondes sur la
financiarisation qui a été abordé par
certains collègues je suis d'accord avec
eux mais il ne faut pas dire qu'on n pas
vu venir la finan isation lorsque la loi
a mis en place les réseaux pour les
optiques pour l'optique et pour les
opticiens nous avions ici au Sénat
dénoncer la mise en place de ces réseaux
et dit que ça entraînerait la mise en
place comme pour le commerce
alimentairire de centrales d'achat qui
ont à l'époque limité les petits
commerces limité les agriculteurs et
cetera de la même façon ces réseaux ont
tuer les petits opticiens et les petits
commerces donc c'est faut on avait déjà
alerté à l'époque sur la
financierisation et on l'a alerté un peu
plus au moment de la mise en place de la
loi sur la biologie ce que nous avions
obtenu au Sénat qui n' pas été retenu
par la suite c'est que dans chaque
centre de prélèvement il y ait un
biologiste ça n pas ça n'est plus le cas
maintenant puisque vous savez que quand
vous allez faire un prélèvement
maintenant il y a quelqu'un qui vous
fait une piqûure on prend votre sang on
l'envoie pour ce qui concerne ma région
c'est-à-dire le voccluse on envoie tout
ça à Lyon et on reçoit un résultat par
par internet donc la financierisation on
en parlera par la suite dans le casre de
la commission ma question est la
suivante vous êtes comme nous chargé
d'équilibrer les dépenses et les
recettes et jusqu'à présent
systématiquement depuis moi en tout cas
je suis sénateur c'estàdire depuis 2004
à chaque PLFSS on nous demande à nous
parlementaires et à vous assurance
maladie de réguler les dépenses et non
pas les recettes il y a un rapport
particulièrement intéressant qui a été
fait à l'Assemblée nationale sur les
exonérations de cotisation sociale ces
exonérations de cotisation sociale
représente actuellement selon ce rapport
un manque de recette qui s'élève à près
de 70 milliards est-il normal que ces
éorations touchent l'ensemble des
salaires et une une des préconisations
de ce rapport c'est de dire de mettre de
supprimer cette orisation
progressivement à partir de
1,5 SMIC que pensez-vous de ce
rapport merci euh qualifé
qualifé merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général
excusez-moi pour ce retard d'abord mais
c'est pas une question c'est plus un
témoignage qui corrobore tout ce qui
vient d'être dit notamment sur la
pertinence des soins je je le dis par
l'expérience de de de plus de 40 ans de
médecin médecins spécialiste
et j'ai malheureusement vu
une une évolution négative vous avez
parlé de
financierisation c'est défiscalisation
aussi pas seulement financierisation
j'ai connu l'époque où il y avait des
ententes préalables pour tout alors que
cette entente en tout cas cette notion a
disparu au fur et à mesure des années et
on a vu et je sais que vous l'avez
dénoncé fleurir beaucoup de choses
toutes ces offici
avec lesquel d'ailleurs vous avez
quelques contentieux notamment en
ophtalmologie mais mais mais pas
seulement il y a aussi des
dispositions pour contourner ces ces ces
multiplications des actes par des
créations de SARL qui font que un malade
passe en shampoing complet chez
l'ensemble des spécialistes présents le
jour même tout ça alors ma question est
simple est-ce qu'il est est-ce qu'il n
pas pertinent de revenir sur cette
notion d'entente préalable au moins pour
certains actes que vous avez visés et
qui qui semblent parfois un peu superflu
merci merci bien Émilienne pouirol
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur beaucoup de choses ont déjà
été dites par mes collègues donc je vais
essayer de restreindre mais le vécu
effectivement des déserts médicaux et
cetera nous le vivons tous je suis
là nous le vivons tous sur le terrain et
je regrette moi aussi que depuis
quelques an on est pas une grande loi
santé à la fois sur l'hôpital qui
s'effondre et c'est un constat on a
rencontré hier encore hier après-midi
encore les directeurs d'hôpitaux qui
sont extrêmement inquiets et à la fois
sur la médecine de ville et vous disiez
que vos agents l'inquiétude par rapport
aux patients qui ont qui sont en al sans
médecin traitant effectivement qui ne
font qu'augmenter j'ai fait très
récemment une réunion dans un centre
d'action sociale non pas par la campagne
puisque j'étais pas renouvelable sur les
médicaux et un agent de la sécule nous
disait mais on essaie de faire nous on
demande aux agents de la sécurité
sociale de contacter les médecins pour
que les médecins prennent un patient de
plus par-ci un patient de plus par là
c'est pas ça qui va régler le problème
de fond vous en êtes bien conscient même
si vous faites des efforts dans ce
sens-là je reviendrai pas aussi sur le
risque de la financierisation la vu ça
vient d'être évoqué encore sur la
biologie
sur sur la radiologie mais on le voit
venir de plus en plus et ma collègue a
évoqué la téléconsultation on le voit
venir de plus en plus sur les soins
primaires le rachat par Rams de
sentretenu par la CroixRouge des choses
de ce genrelà des consultations qui
sont programmé avec des des médecins à
des tarifs inférieur à la consultation
normale qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire
pour lutter contre cette
financiarisation sur les soins primaires
je reviens l'instant sur les prix la
pénurie du médicament Laurence CEN a it
avec un excellent rapport ce printemp
sur lequel nous avons travaillé pendant
5 ou 6 mois le prix du médicament est un
élément mais qu' n'est pas majeur vous
venez de le redire les prix en Suisse en
Espagne au Portugal des génériques sont
plus importants et pourtant ils ont des
pénuries il a été fait dans ce rapport
un certain nombre de préconisations je
n'en vois aucune qui est reprise dans ce
budget et ça me paraît bien dommage
enfin juste sur la remarque d'Alen Milon
c'est quand même amusant qu'on se
retrouve en étant tous les deux à de de
points opposés de la salle tout à fait
d'accord sur l'augmentation de recettes
et sur l'action sur les exonérations
au-delà de 1 C SMIC je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'important effectivement
ça ferait des recettes supplémentaires
qui nous donneraient une bouffée
d'oxygène sur notre
budget bien monsieur ficher pour
terminer oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général un constat
à la veille de chaque pfss on pose la
question de la fraude et la dernière
fois je vous avvez posé la question de
la fraude en disant mais comment se
fait-il qu'on n'est pas plus efficace
pour lutter contre cette frude à chaque
fois vous nous répondez ah ne vous
inquiétez pas on est en cours
d'évaluation on va évaluer la fraude on
va l'identifier et après on prendra des
mesures je pense que s'il y a des
recettes à faire et bien c'est tout
simplement aujourd'hui de réduire cette
fraude voire de l'annuler parce qu'elle
est pas normale on sait on l'identifie
quand même bien aujourd'hui où est la
fraude et je pense qu'il est temps
maintenant d'agir un constat et une une
question alors la presse devrait
quasiment payer la CA d'assurance
maladie c'est le droit aux articles
quotidiens qu'elle produit sur les
situations les plus incroyable en
matière de désinfication médicale mais
et ça rejoint un petit peu la question
d'Émilienne tout à l'heure moi je
voudrais soumettre un cas on a un
témoignage récent d'une maison de
retraite qui refuse l'accueil d'une
personne âgée de 96 ans en disant vous
n'avez pas de médecin référent donc on
ne vous prend pas la
famille ne pas interroge et la
directrice dit non non pas de médecin
pas de pas de place en épad et renvoie
vers l'ARS l'ARS dit il y a pas de
problème dès que quelqu'un est en
difficulté et doit consulter un médecin
il faut consulter la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie qui vous orientera
qui vous qui vous donnera un médecin
dans des délais très brefs alors je
savoir un peu comment ça marche et
est-ce que on peut donner des numéros de
téléphone ENF donner des éléments
extrêmement précis dans le finisterè
c'est 15000 famill qui n'ont pas de
médecin référent merci merci beaucoup
c'est à vous
monsieur merci beaucoup monsieur
Président je vais essayer d'être assez
rapide il évidemment beaucoup de
questions madame Brulin sur le je crois
que la réforme du financement des
établissement de santé vise justement à
à consolider un modèle en lien
avec voilà les trois blocs de de
financement la meilleure reconnaissance
de la qualité de la santé publique et
donc une part laissé à la T mais qui
sera plus faible qu'aujourd'hui et je
pense que ça ça ça va dans un sens qui
est d'ailleurs plutôt consensuel avec
les fédérations hospitalière et de de de
consolider les les finances de de de
l'hôpital même si évidemment il y a une
conjoncture qui est difficile un petit
mot tout de même sur le service des des
caisses primaires qui est sûrement
perfectible je je je d'abord nous
restons un réseau départemental nous
restons sur un maillage de nos accueils
nous avons pris l'engagement dans la
coche de maintenir nos effectifs dédiés
à nos différents canaux de contact euh
toutes les semaines nous traitons 500000
appels téléphoniques tous les jours 2
millions de personnes se connectent au
compte améli tous les toutes les
semaines des centaines de millions de
personnes des centaines de milliers vont
dans les accueils physiques des Caisses
Primaires aujourd'hui nous ouvrons des
droits à la C2S en moins de 15 jours
nous liquidons les arrêts de travail on
va s'améliorer mais entre 25 et 30 jours
c'est des choses qu'on faisait avant
crise et on est en train de rétablir le
le taux desgrochier du téléphone même si
les volumes de sollicitation téléphoniqu
ont beaucoup coup augmenter et ne
reviennent pas à leur niveau
d'avant-crise donc l'offre de service va
continuer à s'améliorer et nous ne
sommes pas un service public qui
pratiquont le numérique de façon
exclusive vous pouvez continuer à aller
dans une caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie pour avoir une attestation de
droit vous l'aurez le canal numérique
c'est très bien en trois clics vous
l'avez sur votre compte amé 43 millions
de personnes ont un compte Amili et de
plus en plus et ceux qui utilisent le
plus le compteamili ce sont les 65 75
ans parce que malheureusement ce sont
ceux qui sont le plus malades et donc
qui ont recours au remboursement de
l'Assurance Maladie sur le tarif des
médecins évidemment ce sera un sujet clé
des négociations j'ai eu l'occasion
d'indiquer que la revalorisation de
26,50 € qui interviendra au 1er novembre
était pour pour moi une étape et donc on
devra aller plus loin mais en effet dans
un équilibre général qui devra aussi
permettre d'avancer sur les sujets
d'accès aux soins sur les sujets de
qualité et de pertinence sur les sujets
de prévention et donc voilà le la
discussion la discussion conventionnelle
n'est pas qu'une discussion faire c'est
aussi une discussion qui doit permettre
d'améliorer l'organisation du système de
santé au passage vous avez euh euh
certains et certaines évoqué évidemment
les sujets de la démographie médicale et
les tensions qui s'exercent elles sont
réelles je je partage à nouveau le fait
que ce que nous mettons en place avec
les dentistes avec les kinés avec les
infirmiers d'une régulation
démographique à l'installation et
notamment des des des logique de zone
surdans où il y a ce remplacement un
pour un le sujet des médecins n'est pas
le même euh ces ces professions
paramédicales ont une démographie
extrêmement dynamique euh on a voilà en
15 ans on a deux fois plus d'infirmiers
aujourd'hui on a 100000 infirmiers
libéraux 75000 kinés c'est des chiffres
qui étaient deux fois moins élevés il y
a il y a il y a 10 ou 15 ans la
démographie médicale ça n'est pas la
même chose les tensions se mesure à peu
près partout donc les réponses ne
peuvent pas être en tout cas pour
l'assurance maladie les mêmes euh madame
Gruny vous m'interrogez sur la
sous-déclaration on on on on repartage à
nouveau bien que ça n'est pas
l'assurance maladie qui fixe les
paramètres de la dotation de la branche
c'est une commission indépendante sous
l'égite de la Cour des comptes qui mène
des travaux d'expertise approfondies et
le gouvernement c'est le gouvernement
qui retient la dotation et retient le
bas de la fourchette le bas de la
fourchette estimé par une commission
indépendante donc je crois que de ce
point de vue-là c'est utile qu'on se
repartage on est en effet mobilisé sur
la lutte contre cette sousdéclaration
nous avons notamment je l'avais évoqué
je crois devant vous engagé en 2000 fin
2022 début 23 une expérimentation pour
aller faire du aller vert presque sur la
sous-déclaration nous sommes allés vers
2800 assurés dont les données de
consommation de soins nous laissai à
penser qu'il pouvit y avoir un lien avec
une pathologie professionnelle et nous
avons engagé des démarches vis-à-vis des
médecins et des assurés pour essayer de
progresser dans la reconnaissance les je
partage avec vous malheureusement qu'à
ce stade les données ne sont pas très
les résultats sont sont peu provants on
on n'arrive pas à avancer sur des
déclarations donc on va relancer une
nouvelle expérimentation on va essayer
de de changer un peu le mode opératoire
et j'espère partager avec devant vous
dans les prochains mois des résultats
meilleurs mais voilà il faut provoquer
chez les assurés et les et les médecins
des des démarches qui sont parfois
peut-être un peu difficiles à réaliser
mais on ne s'arrête pas à ce premier
résultats en 2030 sur les contrôles je
je je je prends bien volontiers le point
et nous nous échangeons régulièrement
avec nos collègues de Bercy et du
contrôle fiscal sur les les enjeux et
les méthodes euh je je crois que le
contrôle de l'assurance maladie se fait
aussi dans des conditions de respect des
professionnels de santé de respect du
contradictoire je vous donne un exemple
très récent nous avons engagé ça a fait
un peu de bruit un contrôle des médecins
qui prescrivent beaucoup d'arrêt de
travail pas ceux qui prescrivent 10 % ou
20 % ou 30 % plus ceux qui prescrivent
deux fois trois fois quatre fois c fois
plus d'arrêt de travail que leurs
collègues en pardon de prendre un peu de
jargon en standardisant les patientelles
évidemment on lisse les différences de
patientell si vous avez une patientelle
âgée d'Al de personnes précaires on
lisse ces différences 1000 médecins
contrôlés 1000 médecins 2 % des médecins
généralistes et bien le dialogue que
nous menons dans dans ces contrôles a
abouti au fait que dans un quart des cas
dans un quart des cas on abandonne le
contrôle parce que la discussion qu'il y
a eu avec le médecin a permis de
montrait qu'au-delà des chiffres qu'on
avait et bien il y a une réalité
territoriale d'une patientelle d'une
situation qui fait que voilà on met de
côté le contrôle et et et et voilà donc
le dialogue honnêtement il fonctionne et
on on peut évidemment bien sûr
s'améliorer sur nos courriers on va
continuer à s'améliorer sur le le le
voilà la la la perception de nos
contrôles ça fait partie aussi de nos
missions et vous m'interpelliez sur les
centres de santé je pense que vous
mesurez l'investissement l'assurance
maladie sur ce sujet-là ce qui me permet
aussi de de répondre à Monsieur fichier
sur le fait qu'on fait pas que
qu'évaluer on a déconventionné un réseau
entier de centes de santé 13 centres de
santé voilà déconventionné c'est la
première fois qu'on le faisait sur un
centre entier on va sur un réseau on va
continuer à le faire il y a d'autres
déconventionnements qui vont se faire y
compris sur des profession de santé
libéraux euh parce que il y a des choses
pas normales qui se passent pardon
d'être un peu simpliste dans la
présentation sur Madame le wou vous
m'interrogez sur le statut des offreurs
de télémédecine alors le le gouvernement
l'année dernière a repris la la
proposition de l'assurance maladie sur
le en effet de de de de définir un
statut de ces offreurs de soins qui
aujourd'hui étent en fait appuyé sur des
centres de santé c'était pas très adapé
c'est l'article 53 la loi de financement
pour 2023 qui se traduit par un projet
de décret d'application qui est en cours
de concertation avec les acteurs mais ça
n'est pas l'assurance maladie qui forth
heureusement fait les fait les textes
réglementaires et donc ça devrait sortir
dans les prochaines semaines et ça
fixera un cadre exigeant de c'est quoi
être un opérateur de téléconsultation
exigence en terme de sécurité de
transparence de déontologie de de de
voilà de de respect des bonnes pratiques
ça devrait avancer madame romaniie vous
m'interroger sur le le le le burnout euh
alors c'est des situations qui peuvent
le cas échéant aboutir à des
déclarations de maladie professionnell
ça me permet
euh de d'évoquer je sais plus monsieur
le Président si je l'ai fait pardon si
je me répète je vais être rapide
l'action que nous menons vis-à-vis des
entreprises qui ont des taux
d'absentéisme atypiques nous sommes
allés voir et plus qu'aller voir nous
accompagnons euh 300 entreprises en
2023 de plus de 150 salariés qui ont des
taux d'absentéisme atypique d'un même
secteur on va avoir une entreprise
s'agit pas de stigmatiser le bâtiment ou
ou d'autres secteurs d'activité qui a
des taux d'absent très é par rapport au
secteur du bâtiment et et on leur
présente les profils d'arrêt de travail
d'accident du travail maladie
professionnelle et on leur propose de
rentrer dans le programme
d'accompagnement de prévention des
troubles musculos solitiqu des troubles
deurps et près de la moitié des
entreprises contactées rentrent dans ces
programmes d'accompagnement donc c'est
plutôt positif monsieur Millon juste sur
les biologistes alors s'il y a quelque
chose qu'il faut absolument maintenir et
c'est la présence d'un biologiste dans
les centres de de de prélèvement et
d'analyse le jour où on fait plus ça euh
ça sera la fin des haricots si vous me
permettez l'expression mais en tout cas
je vous rejoins bien volontiers
là-dessus sur les exonérations de
cotisation c'est un débat qui dépasse
très largement l'assurance maladie je me
permets juste de de partager avec vous
que ces ces exonérations sont compensé à
la sécurité sociale donc bien sûr c'est
un enjeu ça peut être un enjeu de
finances publi mais en tous les cas il y
a pas de perte de recette de l'assurance
maladie sur ces euh sur ces exonérations
euh monsieur sénateur qualifié sur les
ententes préalables ça fait partie des
sujets qu'on est qu'on veut rediscuter
avec les médecins euh on a des
dispositifs d'accord ou d'ententees
préalable qui sont qui ont qui ont qui
on on va dire qui ont mal vieilli et
donc on va essayer de les de les rénover
de les dématérialiser ça fait partie de
nos priorités dans la enfin pas de nos
priorités mais des sujets qu'on va
évoquer avec euh les médecins madame
pomirol sur les le plan d'action
notamment al sans médecin traitant enfin
je je repartage avec vous hein c'est
c'est pas euh c'est pas ponctuel hein
c'est-à-dire on a écrit et on on
dialogue avec les 32000 médecins
libéraux qui voient plusieurs fois le
même patient et qui l'ont pas déclaré
comme médecin traitant on a mobilisé
l'ensemble des CPTs sur ce sujet on est
en train de de voilà de faire des
démarches c'est vrai qui sont qui sont
lourdes mais c'est du voilà d'aller
chercher de mobiliser la la aussi dans
les CPTs la solidarité des médecins
traitants si les 15 médecins
généralistes prennent chacun 3 4 5
patients en al euh si on on prévient le
départ à la retraite pour se répartir
les patients aid entre médecins c'est
des choses qu'on est en train de
faire et voilà ça répond aussi je crois
à la question de Monsieur ficher sur ce
qu'on fait aussi sur les patients en a
sans médecin traitant encore une fois
c'est une mobilisation très forte de
l'assurance maladie qui qui va prendre
du temps pour avoir des résultats parce
qu'encore une fois il y a des phénomènes
lourds en face
mais c'est clairement pas une action
ponctuelle merci beaucoup monsieur le
directeur pour l'ensemble de ces
réponse et donc nous allons continuer
nos travaux voilà donc merci à vous
merci
beaucoup